all right good morning everybody
sorry we're a few minutes late
but we will get started um
i'm going to open the being 906 open the
public hearing on house bill 1100.
if anybody wishes to speak to this there
are pink cards out back
um if you just want to sign in one way
or the other there is a blue sheet
prime sponsors representative sykes uh
he isn't here yet but representative
thank you very much
good morning honorable colleagues in
transportation and welcome back
um i will be presenting house bill 1100
fn for
um representative sykes
uh this bill is relative to changing the
penalties for driving without a license
um
from what i understand
it used to be
a violation
to be driving caught driving without a
driver's license and a number a handful
of years ago it changed to a
misdemeanor um charge
which is an upgraded penalty
i believe that this bill the intent of
this bill is to bring it back to a
violation
to
make it a little more manageable for
those who are perhaps
lower income
have challenges
perhaps didn't have
a license at the time for a number of
reasons but i would
like to defer most of the questions to
the different organizations that are
here we did get a letter of testimony
via email
from them
that i hope you all will have a chance
to read
thank you
any questions
will you take any questions
wow they're letting you have to hook
thank you mr chair can i go back to my
seat or would you like me to stay out
here uh if you're introducing you should
stay over there thank you can i just
and if there's any pink cards if you can
just pass them down that'd be helpful
support all right
this will go up chair recognizes eva
good morning
my name is eva castillo i reside in
manchester i'm part of the new hampshire
immigrant rights network and several
other
networks
for
immigrants and refugees
i'm coming here to ask you to please
revert to
this
the misdemeanor charges for driving
without a license
there is no need to to inflict such
harsh punishment
for somebody
that's driving and committing no other
offense
especially when it's the first time that
they do it you know it really makes no
sense to mark somebody for life and and
mess their
their background
and and their record
for
something that you know it's not even
a big deal unless you're driving drunk
or doing something or you're a habitual
offender
we used to do that in new hampshire
before
and it really makes no sense it can
affect people's ability
to earn a living it can affect people
ability to even
get
school
funding
so you know this is too harsh a
punishment for somebody that that is
just driving
without a license and uh and he's
committing no other crime so
here please
uh you know support
this bill and let's go back to the way
new hampshire used to be we sent you a
letter before signed by all of us
with uh
with uh our support for this bill so i
hope you received it
and
you take into consideration
what we're doing and thank you for
your service to new hampshire for
allowing us to talk all right thank you
any questions will you take any
questions and any questions from the
committee
go ahead represent thompson
uh good morning ma'am good thank you
very much for testifying
um
we have another bill coming up later in
the day
which is going to be relative to the
licensure of non-resident aliens
temporarily
i guess my question is
your request is that based on the fact
non-resident people that are picked up
for
driving without a license are unable to
get a license because of their
immigration status
well right now a lot but this this bill
doesn't necessarily only affect
those people but yes it is a big part of
of the bill people right now are not
entitled to get a driver's license
depending on certain immigration status
so
but this bill affects other you know
like sometimes young people
that
got their you know their
cars or something they haven't had time
to
to to get their driver's license or
haven't made the effort so that affects
them that affects a bunch of different
people
okay thank you very much thank you
okay any other questions from the
committee
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
uh chair recognizes
uh i hope i'm saying this right bruno de
bruto
uh also in support of the bill
representing i'm not sure
what that says but i'll let you mention
it
good morning mr chair good morning
members of the the committee
transportation committee
my name is bruno de brito and i am
president of the new hampshire brazilian
council
so um so the idea of
trying
to
help
immigrants in the state
and people that are not able to to get a
driver's license
in the state because they don't have a
social security number
we
in conjunction with representative sykes
uh representative talaski as well
we
came up with a b with the idea
to revert back
this legislation that had been in place
for many many years and reverted to
um
to criminalizing driving without a
license
so the the idea the goal uh to
to this bill this legislation is to
make a violation when someone is picked
up
driving without a license
and if that person is picked up again
within a year then it becomes a
misdemeanor
if that person doesn't become
doesn't get
pulled over within a year then it goes
back to a violation
so and the reason being is because
many immigrants uh families uh good
people
that you know come to this country uh
seeking a better life
they have to go to work
and unfortunately uh they have to pick
up uh you know their kids in school
drop off you know the
you know drop off you know the kids you
know to
soccer
and you know like many other things that
they have to do on the daily basis
and unfortunately as the at the moment
that they leave
their house they get into their car it
becomes a nightmare for them because you
know they're always afraid that they're
gonna get pulled over and they're gonna
be sent to ice and be placed in removal
proceedings which uh commonly known as
deportation
so this bill would actually
um
help you know like the courts in not
being overcrowded with unnecessary cases
and would help the courts to
be more focused on serious cases
you know serious crimes especially with
opioids
and not really
you know have to deal with these patio
offenses
uh we do have uh support from a lot of
law enforcement they do understand the
need
of uh you know the folks to to drive
back in from work
and we ask you to to please uh you know
support this legislation as well and let
the people drive
in the state
freely
thank you thank you
will you take any questions
yes any questions from the committee
thank you mr chairman
sir uh you mentioned that law
enforcement is
is in support of this could you tell me
who they are
sure yeah so we uh you know like we have
conversations with
um the the southern hampshire uh you
know chiefs uh that's where most of uh
you know like immigrants are are located
in the state
um
and you know like and they do understand
that you know like immigrants the the
majority of them you know they're
they're good people you know these are
you know like families that you know
that come here you know to seek a better
life just as you know like your
ancestors you know came to this country
you know seeking a better life so they
also have you know this understanding uh
but unfortunately you know they do have
to to follow the law and when they come
across um you know with someone who
doesn't have a license they have to to
follow the procedure
follow up follow up
thank you mr chairman
okay i get that
that but you mentioned southern chiefs
i i'm not hearing any names any police
departments could you tell me
sure ones that are supporting you yeah
sure
so we have
nashua we have hudson we have hollis
um
we we have merrimack we have salem okay
thank you
any other questions from the committee
seeing none thank you very much all
right thank you
our chair recognizes
maggie fogarty
am i saying that correctly yes
thank you mr chairman good morning my
name is maggie fogarty i'm the new
hampshire program director for the
american friends service committee which
is a quaker organization working for
human rights
and racial justice
in new hampshire and throughout the
country
and i just want to i don't want to
restate the important points that have
been already made
but i do want a flag for you that you do
have in your email
some written testimony from the new
hampshire immigrant rights network a
statewide coalition of partners working
to advance humane immigration policy at
the federal
state and local levels and this is a
priority bill
for us
you also have a letter from my colleague
co-worker grace kendeke
a member of our afsc staff
i want to just emphasize the context in
which we're making this uh we're
supporting this proposal and that is
that congress for decades has failed to
act to create
a
a coherent
immigration system in the united states
and the result of that including for
many hundreds of families in new
hampshire is that people who have lived
here 10
20 or more years simply do not have in
the current context a path to
regularizing their immigration status
but their lives are here they're raising
their families here they're running
businesses they're members of our
churches and local communities and in a
state that lacks
substantial infrastructure for public
transportation a car is essential so
we've put a lot of people into an
awkward position where they have to risk
this legal consequence simply to get
their child to a doctor's appointment to
get to a job etc
so this is a proposal that
in the context of a broader national
conversation about reducing some of the
criminalization in our society and
finding more thoughtful responses to
community problems this would give a
small tool
uh to or or an opening for law
enforcement to respond
uh in more thoughtful ways
again not for habitual offenders but for
somebody who one time is pulled over
and found to be driving without a
license so for that reason
we are very much in support of this bill
you may know that for people who who do
have a path to some sort of immigration
relief having even a misdemeanor or a
couple of misdemeanors on very minor
offenses can be enough to deny them
the the relief that they are trying to
get so we think it's a simple but very
effective step that we could take for a
healthier community
thank you any questions from the
committee
uh first off i want
can you all go there we go
first off i want to apologize to the
committee and to the people who made the
trek here i'm sorry i was a few minutes
late to introduce my own bill
the question i have for you is is it not
true that
this bill would also help for instance a
single working parent
who
for no reason or other who happened to
be
a long-standing citizen of this country
in this state
neglected to get his license
renewed immediately and then discovered
the mistake
based on being stopped and that would
then in turn create a misdemeanor which
is of course much more serious
that is absolutely correct there are so
many people living in our state for whom
their poverty is extremely costly
and so the even the cost of renewing a
license or the the chaos of holding
multiple jobs while caring for a family
and deadlines pass and people don't
renew their licenses then triggers
consequences that can then cause further
problems in their lives so it is true
that they would clearly benefit from
this as well
follow up
is it also not true that this um
particular passage of our state laws
back in 2015 it was indeed a uh
violation
and that was a change at that time
and now we're just trying to revert back
to where it was that's right that is
representative gorski
thank you mr chairman
dan thank you miss fogerty for
testifying today i have a question for
you mentioned
that if someone is convicted or
currently as a misdemeanor their life is
impacted could you elaborate more
of kind of if that happens kind of
what happens if in fact they get
charged with a misdemeanor
and do you mean in the immigration
context or in just a broad range of
broad range of context
uh yes well certainly uh in the
immigration context to have one or more
misdemeanors
can
so negatively impact a person's
application for an immigration relief of
some kind that it could be justification
for them being denied which then can
lead to their detention and their
deportation so those consequences are
are acute
but not sadly not rare
in the course of life of someone who's
not in the immigration legal system
accumulated criminal
offenses
negatively impact a future setting in
which they may need to be in court or
they are
trying to make a case as a reliable
person i mean someone who's looking at
their record could see that as
a negative mark that perhaps denies them
housing or denies them some kind of loan
or some other
some other benefits like that or that
accentuates criminal legal consequences
if if something else happens
yeah
any further questions from the committee
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
last person i have signed up to speak
mr richard head representing the
judicial branch
not taking a position on the bill
good morning mr chairman members of the
committee my name is richard head i'm
the government affairs coordinator for
the judicial branch i'm passing around a
letter that's also in your email we have
a request on this bill to
we have no position on the on the policy
of the bill we do have a request that
the effective date be changed to january
1 2023
and as is explained in the letter
there's a statute that governs effective
dates rsa 14 colon 9-a
and it says each law affecting judicial
practice and procedure or establishing
or eliminating criminal procedure or
prohibition blah blah blah shall take
effect on the january one following
passage
and and the reason for that is there are
just a large number of bills that
have an impact on a
on statutes that deal with
with crimes with judicial practice and
procedure
and so for example in this bill
it would eliminate
the paragraph numbers it would change
the the nature of the sentence so
when an officer when a when a law
enforcement officer is charging a crime
we have a system under j-1 in the
uniform charge table which identifies
what the crime is what the paragraph is
of the statute what the line is
essentially of the statute and what is
the what is the penalty
any time that changes the j-1 uniform
charge table has to be amended and then
within the judicial branch our system
called odyssey has essentially the same
thing every line of a criminal statute
has a line in our odyssey system and
every time there's a change to that our
system has to change in order to make
sure that we are properly recording the
the charge that has been filed in the
court it takes a little bit of time to
get all of those changes in both with
the department of safety the attorney
general's office and the judicial branch
in order to make all of these things
line up so we do ask that without any
regard to the policy that if this bill
proceeds um that the effective date be
changed january 1 2023 thank you and be
happy to take any questions thank you
and for the committee i don't know if
you remember we did make this change uh
and as an amendment uh to a bill last
year for the same reasons
um i guess i should have emailed you
back and saved you the trip but yeah and
there's actually a bill this afternoon
and and maybe i can stop somebody else
from coming at one o'clock you have
house bill 1640 we have the the same
written testimony
thank you any questions from the
committee
seeing none thank you very much thank
you mr chairman uh that's the last
person i have signed up to speak is
there anybody else that wishes to speak
the house bill 1100.
seeing that i'm going to close the
next up at 9 30
and we're right on
morning
uh
oh
okay ladies and gentlemen being 9 32.
i'm going to open up the public hearing
on house bill 1461 fn
uh this is increasing the penalties for
littering
um
chair introduces representative green
good morning chair and good morning
honorable committee my name is dennis
green i'm from rockingham district 13. i
represent hampstead in kingston
i brought this bill forth because
there's been much littering on our
highways and it doesn't seem to get
stopped or cleaned up
i've witnessed it many times and
i've spoken to several local police
departments i've spoke to the high
sheriff of rockingham county
and i've been out with state troopers
before the covid uh out of troop a
and the reason i increased this because
we have a beautiful state here and
there's no need of it to be destroyed
it's live free or dying not to trash our
state
so
in this past weekend i noticed i was in
seabrook
i stopped at market basket
and as i was getting out i was stepping
on a trash bag
while a supermarket bag
i picked it up and inside the bag
was somebody's bones from a roasted
chicken that they must have gotten into
a market basket and they just tossed it
out of their car
and
yesterday i was walking my dog
and i happened to see a car stop over by
a church where i was walking my dog and
a guy tossed something out
so i said well i'll check it out later
and as i walked by where he stopped
there was a bottle
appears to be like a liquor bottle
and it was filled with urine
and it was disgusting
and because i didn't have gloves on i
wasn't going to touch it but i will pick
it up
and
talking with the police departments
the fine
is really not that much right now
compared to other things that they could
be stopping people for
so they said if there was an increase in
the penalty it might be worthwhile i'm
not looking to change the
to a fennel a felony
but i am looking to increase the fine to
stop the trash
and i'd be glad to take any questions
thank you any questions from the
committee
thank you very much uh representative
greene um i do have one question
in the methodology it uh calls on the
third offense for
the driver's license to be suspended but
it doesn't specifically state for how
long
i think that would be the discretion of
the judge
okay all right
all right thank you very much you're
welcome any further questions
i believe it's like a hundred and ten
dollars you could ask these troopers for
sure but i'm not 100 sure
correct
any further questions from the committee
representative gorski
thank you mr chairman uh in terms of the
and thank you representative greene for
testifying
um the 300 and 500 dollar figures how
did those
kind of come how do those get calculated
why 300 500
it's like inflation
our inflation our economy has gone way
high the
gasoline has gone up
our groceries have gone up and i just
says i want to send a message to stop it
and the only way you're going to send a
message is to increase the fines to a
point
follow-up follow-up why not make the
first one 500.
you can change that
thank you you're welcome
any further questions from the committee
seeing none thank you very much
thank you
um i do not have anybody else signed up
to speak on this is there anybody else
that wishes to i think he had a hand up
thank you
um
do you have is it possible to get um
something like that universal code of
penalties that the
the department of justice
or the you know keeps and get that to us
so we can compare this request with all
the other offenses that might exist
so that we can put it into perspective
and i'm sort of looking at the gentleman
in the back
which defines um under new hampshire
code uh littering for a natural person
is uh listed as a 62 first offense fine
all by 124
subsequent fine
the non-natural person showing must
yeah
i understand that we're able to
in a discrete kind of way to compare
littering
where it was and where it is what i'm
trying to get
the information to is
how does this compare to other motor
vehicle
stops if you will or violations
one of the problems we've had in the
past i don't i guess i would continue
past is that we have tried to increase
some fines and there's a lot of pushback
because of
you know and so without having that
knowledge of the basis of what how it
compares to many other offenses
if this helps because it doesn't sound
like they've got the information here
that is something we can look up and
have it before we execute the bill that
would be great okay thank you mr
chairman thank you this is her you're
welcome
thank you thank you for taking my
question um i'm just curious if in your
research before filing this bill you got
any numbers on the number of violations
of citations actually issued i'm just i
know our law enforcement is pulled
really thin and
i'm not sure that
directing them to you know pull cards
over handout violations for this is the
best use of their time so i'm just
wondering the extent of what we're
talking about the number of litterers
that actually get
caught and cited that's why i increased
the fine because their time is worth a
lot more than 62
for pulling a car over for throwing
something out
and that's why i put the
increase up to 300 along with the fact
but
what
else were you looking for
i'm just curious if you know the uh the
number of violations that were issued in
the last year or the year prior no i
don't but i can almost say that if daily
uh
i wouldn't say every day but i'll bet
you three times a week i have seen it
okay well
i don't know if that data is even
available but we can look for it as well
thank you
any further questions from the committee
seeing none thank you very much thank
you i see nobody else in the public that
wishes to speak i'm going to close the
public hearing on house bill
yes
call to order
transportation meeting uh the next
bill before us is house bill
1489 f n relative to motor vehicle title
exemptions
the first speaker call up is
priscilla vaughn is that correct
oh oh sorry
um aidan would you like to introduce the
bill sorry about that
i guess i just want to jump the gun i
thank you mr chairman um okay that's
14.89
relative to motor vehicle title
exceptions this bill exempts vehicles
that are seven years or older from
needing a current certificate of title
in order to be registered
thank you representative any
any questions for the representative
now i can call
is that better yes
my name is priscilla vaughn i've been
working for the state of new hampshire
for close to 40 years i run the bureau
of title and anti-theft
i'm the administrator
this bill is a little concerning
it will cost the state of new hampshire
fi approximately 5 million dollars
it's also going to also lose revenue
excuse me lose revenue of 5 million
dollars
local revenue for the town and city
we did an estimate in the last three
years 2018 19 and 20 of the revenue
this has a little conflict with the
federal
odometer statement
the federal law 580.17
it requires
us to
disclose odometers on vehicles that are
sold
for a 20-year period
it was 10 it's graduating now to a
20-year period
so this would be pretty difficult to be
able to disclose your odometer when you
if you don't have a title because the
title has the odometer
information on the back
and that's what you pass on to the buyer
is a title
the other issue that the state has is um
salvage vehicles
there's a lot of stakeholders involved
you have the insurance companies you
have the dealers you have uh
private individuals you have lien
holders that can lean
lend money on vehicles and if they don't
have a perfected lien they're going to
have a very difficult time getting a
loan
there's just a lot of stakeholders
involved and this is a very short period
of time a 2015 is a fairly new car
is a new car obviously for a lot of
people and there's a lot of
vehicles that are older than that
that are on the road
so i have a feeling that this is going
that's all i have okay
thank you any questions
representative dollersky
thank you thank you for taking my
question in very simple layman's terms
can you tell me what the um purpose of a
title is
the perfect the perfection of a title
would be you can disclose um odometer
fraud
brands so if you're buying a car right
now if you buy a car that's a 1999 you
don't know what you're getting
but if you buy a car that's a 2000 and
newer you know on that title it shows
that's proof of ownership
it shows if there's any brands if the
odometer has been rolled back
it shows if it's been salvaged flood
rebuilt there's a lot of good
information for consumer protection and
safety for our roads in new hampshire
it's very important to have a title
thank you
representative sykes did you have a
question
oh that was the question
any other questions from the committee
i will now call dan bennett from the new
hampshire auto dealers association
thank you and good morning mr chairman
members of the committee it's great to
see you all here this morning my name is
dan bennett from the new hampshire auto
dealers association we are the trade
group for about 500 businesses in new
hampshire about 14 000 employees
we are the car truck motorcycle
snowmobile atv construction farm
equipment dealers
as well as collision repair
so a lot of businesses in all corners in
all counties of the states
respectfully we oppose hb 1489
for four main reasons uh they are um
the motor vehicle title is a formal
document that that uh
that tracks a vehicle through its life
and ensures and proves its ownership um
it's what shows that you have the your
personal property is protected and that
you have the the claim of ownership to
that vehicle um as mentioned it's a
formal document uh if we relied simply
on a bill of sale
i could take a slip up paper from my
legal pad and meet you on the hallway
and make up a bill of sale for your real
quick you could do it on a cocktail
napkin at the barley house so
this is a formal document that's blessed
both by the uh the state
and our federal government through the
without the title process new hampshire
would become a destination for for
stolen vehicles and vehicle fraud um
because without that formal document
process just that simple bill sale flip
it real quick never be able to prove
ownership
and this would become a hotbed for it um
including even
we have very low fees there's no proof
of insurance um even with a title it's
27 fee very low uh nationwide so um
another thing that i'll mention real
quick the average age of vehicles is 12
years rl poke recently released it's a
little over 12 years so um with this
cutting it off at seven
would be incredibly problematic uh over
85 of the vehicles in the marketplace
are financed today okay so what a bank
uses when they decide to loan you money
to buy that car
is the title that's how they secure
their interest before they loan you x
amount of dollars they take hold of that
title until you pay them off and when
that loan is completed and paid off then
you now have the ownership of that
vehicle so that title document is key in
the motor vehicle financing industry so
with 85 percent of vehicles being
financed if you eliminate the titling
process after seven years it will
decimate the used vehicle marketplace
for for citizens all over the state so
um
that's really uh the one last thing i'll
say is uh i know you heard from
priscilla vaughn
the dealers association we represent
both independent and franchise dealers
all over the state
so we have a tremendous amount of
interaction with them um
and and what i would like to say is the
dmv the title bureau ms vaughn and her
staff do a do a tremendous job ensuring
what can be a complicated process with
titles that come from different states
and different places to really provide
great customer service for um
for new hampshire citizens and new
hampshire businesses
the system right now really does work uh
and we
testify and verify that so um with that
being said um i'll take any questions if
there are any
any questions
other states say maine new hampshire i
mean maine massachusetts
vermont what are their title programs
like and what is the length of time
before you need to have a
before you no longer need one
um so represent thank you for the
question unfortunately i don't have all
um 50 state title laws in um you know
off the top tip of my tongue i know that
uh we can find a document really is he
doing a 50-state summary and we can get
it over to you ms vaughn or one of her
staff may know here but if not i'll
certainly follow up because i'm sure the
the the national agency that deals with
titling ninvitis has a
quick state summary but all states title
vehicles um
in some
form or fashion okay
thank you
that would be good anyway representative
telersky
thank you thank you for taking my
question i don't want you to
put words in the sponsor's mouth since
he's not here but i really don't
understand
what
this bill what the reasoning behind it
who would benefit from this and why this
would be
i don't know if that's an appropriate
question to ask mr chair yeah it might
not be all right i guess i i will ask
behind the scenes thank you yeah you can
do that
thank you representative
any further questions
cnn thank you mr bennett thank you
does anyone else wish to testify who
hasn't not filled a pink card or
whatever from
seeing none
i close
donovan would you get the blue
seat that's on that table there and
bring it up
please
they didn't have to do this but they did
leave it with all of those
oh and we'll do it duh yes i'll keep the
okay the next one is gonna be
at 10 thirty
okay i'll call the meeting back to order
next up is house bill 1615
fn relative to driver education and
the prime sponsor is representative
susan army
right turn turn turn your mic on ah
thank you right you've got the same ones
we do and we're still learning them
yes we are
hey thank you very much for hearing me
today
uh
i'm coming to you today as the
originator of dedicated funds oversight
in this legislature not as the current
clerk of the joint committee on
dedicated funds but this bill originates
from there the joint committee has not
weighed in on this issue as we consider
all
things like this should start with the
so here i am
the bill in its current state is
defective since i and some of the new
hampshire driver education teachers
association members
some of them here
did not have enough time to hash out all
the details
we hope you will be willing to take this
bill to interim study to allow these to
be decided
i approach this first and foremost as a
violation of the principles of our
dedicated funds
we have a driver training fund which in
the 2011 budget bill was rated to
provide funding
primarily for the general fund and the
state's detective bureau
not for driver education
and it was made permanent in the budget
the money comes from vanity plate fees
arguably a highway fund item
the driving
training fund was established to
subsidize public schools costs of
providing driver training to their
students
and to pay for the division of motor
vehicles administrative and student
manual costs
of the program
the 2011 budget decision removed the
requirement that public schools provide
this training and removed the subsidy
this meant that students now
must pay themselves or wait until age 18
to pass tests and acquire licenses
based on inadequate training
unless they have parents who are very
good drivers
this reduces road safety across the
state
costs of the private training now range
between i think it's four hundred to
seven hundred dollars in different towns
and areas
which is difficult for many many
families to afford
i apologize for my voice i have damaged
lungs and
in fy 21
3.3
of this dedicated fund paid for the dos
costs
and the dmv apparently has stopped
paying for the driving class workbooks
although
uh and the driver training schools are
having to print them out themselves
because a workbook needs to be on paper
usually
20 was transferred to the detective's
although their positions would more
appropriately have been funded from the
general fund
the general fund received 76.7
of the funds collected for driver
training in an unusual lapse that occurs
at the beginning of the biennium instead
of at the end
because of what was done
the structure of driver education has
shifted markedly there is almost no
public school which provides driver
education itself
it is all carried out by private driving
schools which are trying to balance
between the labor intensive work they do
to produce responsible drivers and the
inability of many potential students to
pay
removing half the revenue
being used for other purposes
including the detectives bureau can
cause pain in other places
in my personal opinion
the state could afford to subsidize the
process
by up to four hundred dollars per
student by restricting it to lower
income students
those with free or
free or reduced lunch or in private
schools
a similar program
uh
or in private schools a similar program
used by them to qualify their low-income
students
and the lapse would be moved
at the beginning of
fy24
next year to the end of the biennium
like all other lapses in dedicated funds
which would allow the finance committees
to move the positions funded in the
detectives bureau to the general fund
but the main focus
for you
is driver and road safety
when someone is tailgating you at 75
miles an hour in the travel lane it just
happened to me several times on the way
down
or veering in front of you to catch an
exit or a break in the traffic
or driving at 80 miles an hour on a
slippery road
remember how we have been educating or
not educating the driving students since
2012.
thank you
thank you representative are you able to
take questions
as much as i can okay any questions from
the committee
representative talersky
thank you representative almi for taking
my question um
we hear often about the cost of driver's
education so i was very interested in
seeing this come through and excited
about the possibility um
can you go into a little more detail
about what the problems might be is
there any way they could be fixed with
an amendment or is it something that's
going to take more long-term discussions
uh well
there within the
the driver training group
on
there are differences of how they are
being paid as i understand it
and
those
perhaps could be ironed out fairly
quickly
on the other question is one of
per student
could get past the finance committee if
this goes to the finance committee
and i don't know if it's an early bill
it should be an early bill
99 sure that it is and it would either
go to my committee which is ways and
means and does dedicated funds they seem
to be a little erratic they always have
been erratic about whether we get them
or finance gets them
but there is a question of
as the bill is written right now it goes
to absolutely everybody including at
exeter academy
and
it ends up being over three million
dollars a year
i know my committee knows that most
people think we have a terrific surplus
right now
this year
mostly because of the federal funds
uh stimulus but
on
we have a
a uh debit coming in
march april that could be as much as 90
to 100 million dollars
so
we still are
being pretty tight in our financing in
this state
that's based on something that we did
last year to
return
the money that we had taxed for the ppp
loans to the businesses
so we really
do need to watch what we're doing to our
representative korski
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative almighty for taking my
question if something like this was
passed do we have any estimates
or a range of how many students
i think
that would come better from
from the
head of the
new hampshire driver education teachers
association
i'm
i've seen an estimate and i can't
remember
what it is it's
it's uh i think several thousands but
she'll she'll know much better okay
thank you yeah she'll be the next
speaker representative mccorsky
any other questions for this witness
next is sharon cameron
from
nhdeta
i'll be short and quick sir thank you
thank you for the opportunity to speak
this
morning a new hampshire diversity could
you identify yourself for the record
please of course i'm sorry sharon
cameron past president of the new
hampshire driver's ed teachers
association
new hampshire driver's teachers
association supports this effort and
this bill and we look forward to working
with the sponsor
that's it i'll be happy to take
questions we love it
any questions from the committee
representative
thank you mr chairman and thank you miss
cameron for testifying i guess i'll
reiterate my question
how many students would take what's the
estimate of how many students could take
advantage of this program if something
like this was passed
sure so the last time that i asked the
um
holly who was the administrator at the
dmv she told me about fifteen thousand
i've seen since then an average of about
twelve thousand seven hundred students a
year who take driver's ed okay the state
might be able to
get more accurate numbers than that
representative thompson
um i've seen the 12 700 figure but
um i believe the previous witness
suggested that there if we were to do
this on a
on a based on a low income
is there any estimate how many people
that would eliminate
what we'd end up with for total i
wouldn't have that information sir i'm
sorry okay thank you
any other questions
seeing none thank you
thank you
next up would be
steve lavoie and joe ebert from the dos
anytime
good morning steve lavoie director of
administration for the department of
safety and with me is captain joe ebert
who runs the state police investigation
services bureau
first off i just wanted to let the
committee know that the department
is is neutral on the concept of
distributing funds to the driver ed
schools for this purpose um however we
are opposed to the bill as it's
currently written
the reason being that it eliminates 1.5
million dollars in funding that
currently supports the detectives bureau
or the investigative services bureau at
new hampshire state police
that that funding
represents a 13 reduction in
appropriations that was budgeted for
through the budget process and would be
eliminated effective july 1 of of 2022
obviously that would have a significant
impact on
state police and on the bureau and would
result in a reduction in force and i
turn it over to captain ebert to to give
the committee some testimony on what
good morning everyone
excuse me for the purpose of the record
my name is joe ebert it's e-b-e-r-t
and as steve mentioned i am the
commander of the investigative services
bureau which is our detective bureau
within the state police
i just very quickly wanted to go over
what that entails and and what a budget
cut would mean
clearly uh it would mean layoffs or the
reduction of certain staff positions um
and these are the uh the units they're
in uh incorporated within investigative
services so you have the uh terrorism
and intelligence unit
the terrorism and intelligence unit
staffs the state's fusion center every
state has an intelligence fusion center
and our terrorism and intelligence unit
is
all tdwi to the
the fusion center with the exception of
one position which is uh assigned to the
fbi for the joint terrorism task force
so uh we would be tasked with uh
spreading spreading this reduction in
manpower over all of the units so
someone would
some position would need to be reduced
in there
you have the special investigations unit
special investigations unit is your
cyber crime unit for the state of new
hampshire they do everything from
network intrusions
we almost uh exclusively concentrate on
state entities but they do network
intrusions they do
when there is some type of cyber enabled
crime
and of course they are involved in the
exchange of child pornography
investigations very heavily
you have your narcotics unit your
narcotics investigations unit
currently the state as i'm sure everyone
on the committee is where the state is
suffering from
the opioid epidemic
but we have recently seen a significant
increase in both cocaine and
methamphetamine into the state of new
hampshire
in just the past six months i i can
testify to the notion that your
narcotics unit which concentrates on
mid-level drug dealers has taken
or prohibited from entering the the
state of new hampshire kilo upon kilo of
uh
illicit drug
and lastly you have your major crime
unit
the major crime unit in the state police
covers the vast majority of homicides
within the state uh they also are the
sole entity for investigating
officer-involved shootings uh in
accordance and with oversight of the
attorney general's office
i having been involved with the major
crime unit for
over 10 years i can tell you that there
is
there is nothing that is more important
than seeking justice for the family
and the friends of someone whose life
has been taken via homicide
so we take that responsibility very
seriously we run on a very very limited
budget and limited manpower and that is
the case with every state entity so i i
don't say that as if somehow we are
being singled out
that's just the nature of the state of
new hampshire i've lived here my whole
life i've gotten used to that i've
worked here for 20 years i know that
that's the way that things go
but a reduction in the staffing within
that particular unit would truly mean a
reduction in the safety for the citizens
of new hampshire
so those are the the four major units
within the investigative services bureau
i appreciate very much the opportunity
to talk to you this morning and
i'm more than willing to take any
questions as i'm sure the director is as
well
thank you commander for taking my
question um
can you tell me what
the new hampshire state police budget
overall is what that number is
actually i'm going to defer to director
levoy on that uh that that's
something that he's likely more able to
and i hesitate to give you a number off
the top of my head for the the entire
department this bureau
is over 11 million dollars yeah i i got
that from the handouts that you gave us
so is it possible for you to send that
information to us i absolutely can okay
because i'm i'm trying to measure the
impact of
the lost revenues
as matched against the whole department
right rather than just your bureau
because i understand there's a huge
and and i can i can certainly provide
that information but i would just
caution that the division of state
police is funded with many different
revenue sources and there's a several
mixed funded there's highway funds
turnpike other dedicated so it's it's
complex and i'll be happy to provide you
any other members from the committee
representative ankerberg
oh i'm sorry
representative you put your hand up
thank you thank you for taking my
question um i'm looking at the rsa in
question 26352
for the driver training fund and i'm
wondering if either one of you can give
me
a little history
as to that change that happened in 2015
or 2016 to redirect these funds
um
why that happened and
if you can give me any connection
obviously the new hampshire state police
and all of your your departments that
you just listed are obviously vital to
the safety of our state but
is there any connection whatsoever
to
driver education and
for the most part teen safety driving on
the roads if you can try to make some
kind of connection on how that came
so i i can
try and answer this question uh the
director and i were actually having this
uh conversation right before we came in
uh to testify
i don't know the the specific reason for
why that uh why those funds were
directed toward the division of state
police and i've found myself in a
position over the last uh five years of
coming over to testify that oftentimes
a piece of
the budget that is allocated to the
state police and i can't give context
for
why it is that uh it ended up that way
all i can say is that having testified
in the past there was there must have
been a reason and i i realized that
that's very vague but there must have
been a reason somebody came in before
committee just like this gave compelling
uh compelling reason as to why these
funds should be diverted
but one thing i do try and steer clear
of is is saying whether or not i find
that to be legitimate somebody at that
time found that to be a legitimate use
for those funds and i can tell you that
uh currently we rely on those funds but
as to
your specific question ma'am i i don't
know why it is that they are allocated
to us
yeah and i i i'd agree with uh with the
captain and i just add that um
uh
as you mentioned these funds are are
budgeted through the the the biennial
budget process um
by the legislature every every biennium
and we've relied on those within this
area to fund the detectives bureau
that doesn't mean that future funding
needs to be supported with these funds
if other funds are available
they can certainly be utilized but the
key here is maintaining the existing
level of service that they're able to
provide but as far as the nexus i think
if you read the language in the law it's
clearly um it's it's silent um for a
purpose for a reason and that's because
there may not be a direct nexus to these
funds
anyone else
seeing none thank you for your testimony
wish to speak any from the audience on
this bill
okay
seeing none i close
oh well i need to
all three of you
so you too i'll make sure you're
together
um
yeah i need one for tom i need one for
me
hang on there
uh yep yep
well these are extras do you already
have a copy of this proposed amendment
all right i'll put this baby over here
how many freaking handouts you gonna
pass these on there's another one
another set see i don't want to make
sure i got one for him
you have one for tom yeah i do i make
sure
being
11 o'clock i'll open up the public
hearing on house bill 1208 fn
relative to driver education
there we go and it's all fixed thank you
mr chairman thank you members of the
community i'm representative tim lang i
am a third term rep uh for the belknap
for belknap four representing the towns
of samerton and tilton i'm the current
chair of fish and game
how you have before you uh a bill a
relative the driver's education this
bill is fairly simple and simple in its
process what it seeks to do is allow
parents the ability to choose whether or
not to send their child to a commercial
driver's education program or to perform
the driver's education program
themselves
as i probably don't have to tell all you
but i probably will because that's the
way we are
is that if you don't know that parents
teach already a majority of especially
on-road driving that 40 hours of the
driving is taught by parents already
so any significant driving habits or
driving things are already taught by the
parents
so just to give you a couple statistics
and in the closest the newest study i
could find was from the state of
washington department of transportation
in 2020 that said there are 19 states
that currently don't have a driver's
education requirement
there are 16 states that overlap with
those that can overlap that also do
provide for an online driver's education
program full drivers education program
online
there was a colorado study but i will
say that it's going on 10 years old now
that did a study on accidents and
violations relative to driver's ed
non-driver's ed and it came back it
black better freight inconclusive there
was no statistically
large deviation in
students that took driver's ed and got a
violation of students didn't take driver
didn't got a violation
um
so
what are we trying to do here again the
idea is to bring back
um
you know what used to be our traditional
and you know probably a good portion of
the people in this room were taught to
drive by their parents and i would make
the assumption that most years are good
drivers
and so again you know the idea is to
allow those parents that want to to be
able to still provide the requirements
of drivers education so they still have
to provide the classroom training they
still have to provide on-the-road
training and they have to self-certify
that those things have been done
and then they would present that
self-certification to dmv and dmv would
waive the requirement for a formal
formal driver's education or commercial
which is probably the most important
word in this conversation is commercial
drivers education program
it's one of the few places in the state
that the state mandates a private
citizen must take a commercial uh
activity and that commercial activity
cost the average now is over seven
hundred dollars
um i'll give you the anecdotal evidence
of my son when i went to go have my son
take the class i had to wait six months
because there was no availability for
class so my son while eligible to drive
and i could have taught him how to drive
unless i wanted to drive to concord or
hook set or or south or way up north
there was nothing in my region in the
laconia lakes regional region i could
have taken a class i had to wait six
months for him to take a class
and so again
i think these burdens we put on parents
um
are are troublesome and again it's the
only place where the state forces us to
say you have to pay a private entity 700
in order to have the privilege of
driving um for people and yet when you
turn 18 so you can be 17 years 364 days
old
and you have to have a driver's
education requirement to get a license
uh eight at 18 years old boom no
driver's edge requirement you can drive
you're considered just as safe on the
road
i think there's a lot of consistency in
that conversation
um
going on uh
last term we had this bill and i i was
in the speaker's office in the deputy
speaker's office discussing why this
bill was itled and what the concern was
and that i could try to overcome
the concern was blatantly said
unintended consequences we're afraid
that'll raise rates for all drivers in
the state of new hampshire if we do away
with the driver's education requirement
so doing my due diligence i went over to
the new hampshire insurance department i
met with the new hampshire assurance
department and they did whatever they do
in the back end and they came back and
said there will be no increase in
driver's costs
for the general public
if this bill were to pass what they did
say was parents would make the option
whether or not they want the discount
that's provided by driver's education or
not
that would be the only loss is if a
parent chose to self-certify
then they would not be entitled to the
driver's education program however
there's a caveat to that there are some
states and some insurance companies that
if you use certain um home school
curriculum do allow certification for
driver's education as long as you
certify that you went through that
curriculum so even giving a parent the
choice doesn't necessitate that they're
going to give up their discount the
discount is still a possibility if they
if they follow the curriculum for
homeschooling so to speak of driver's
education
um
so again i want to be clear there's no
rate increase for the general public in
the state of new hampshire if this law
was to pass you would not see car
insurance rates increase
at least due to this reason can't tell
what the insurance companies will do for
um one of the interesting conversations
i had around this bill was i was
presenting this build to um to a rotary
club and in the rotary club we had
superintendents and a couple principals
from other schools
they indicated that this is a huge
problem for their schools because it
creates it severely creates a have and
have-nots situation where there are
parents where you have single families
single-parent families struggling and
those kids struggle to get a driver to
pay 700 dollars for a driver's ed class
and then never mind the time the parent
has to take to take the child to that
class
and they would much rather make the time
and teach their child and not give up
both
um and the school in this case said that
if this bill were to pass they would
easily see them bringing back an
elective to teach the rules of the road
class right here's the laws here's what
a black and white sign means here's what
yellow means it doesn't mean go faster
it means caution
you know and those kind of things they
would teach all the driver's ed
requirements
as part of the course and classroom
portion as part of a high school
elective instead right now the schools
don't want a they can't go near unless
they want to certify certified drivers
at instructors and b there's the whole
issue of driving they don't want the
liability of driving by allowing this
model that we would allow our high
schools to be able to bring back the
driver's ed book piece of this the the
classroom piece of this into high
schools for a half a credit and be able
to allow the parents to teach the
practical piece
safety is the next argument everybody
gives me about this bill is how we can
ensure that drivers on the road are safe
and the answer that is we already do
that
department of motor vehicle gives two
exams you have a written exam which is
your basic book exam make sure you know
the rules of the road and if you don't
pass that exam number one you don't get
a driver's license the second one is we
do a practical exam so a driver's dmv
employee takes a citizen on the road and
makes them drive a vehicle if they're a
first-time driver to prove they can
drive
so we have two gatekeepers at this at
this to keep safe drivers on the road
these are the same gatekeepers that keep
keep that 18 year old who's never taken
driver's head off the road if he's not a
good driver he's never taken driver's ed
first-time licensee has to go through
that same practicum has to take the
written exam has to take the practical
exam has to pass both while they're off
the road your gatekeepers are right back
there in uniform the
department of motor vehicle
employees that do the tests they are
keeping it not the drivers education
programs are keeping unsafe drivers they
may make better drivers but they don't
keep the unsafe ones off the road your
unsafe drivers are kept off the road by
our state agency and i my opinion is
they do a good job
[Music]
the one thing
the last piece i'll say is i think it's
extremely important to understand that
this the job of the state is to make
sure we have safe drivers on the road
that's dmv's job it is not the job of
the state to make sure commercial
entities have a forced
uh group of citizens that must go to pay
to take a class from them that's not our
job is to keep these entities open or
thriving or anything else i hope they do
because i think there'll be plenty of
parents who will still opt for a
commercial driver's education program
but it should never be the obligation of
the state to say the reason we can't
close this loophole allow parents to do
this i'm afraid we won't have enough
driver's education programs that's not
our job to keep a commercial entity a
private commercial entity open
we should not be doing that as a rule
we should be if there's a safety issue
we've addressed it with dmv with the
testing and if we think that testing
needs to be more robust and that's where
we deal with it and the safety issue not
at a private commercial entity
and with that i'll be happy to take
questions
thank you representative any questions
from the committee
representative
thank you thank you for taking my
question so the one of the things that
jumps out to me is the usage of the
phrase responsible adult
and
by your own discussion an 18 year old
can go in on his 18th birthday and take
the written exam in the road exam
without driver's ed and get their
license does that mean the next day they
can
go in and educate a 16 year old on all
the rules of the road and be the
responsible adult or how do you define
that so the requirements i think if you
look in the chapter it's not in this
section i think it's in another section
says that responsible adults 25 or older
so i get on my 29 year old teach it's
not in this chapter it's in the chapter
defining how who's allowed to do the 40
hours
that's already in statute again remember
some of this is already in statute the
40 hours is already required and that's
already defined what a responsible
person is um the amendment of one thing
i apologize the amendment you see in
front of you i forgot to give the agency
rulemaking authority to be able to
create the forms and necessary
regulations they need around it so the
last it just changes section five and
adds a last line granting rulemaking
authority to the agency to be able to
create the forms i serve on jal cars so
i see them on a regular basis i've been
there for three terms
and they come in and you know in a law
like this they would need to create a
form or amend a form which would go
through rule making process and i needed
to give them the authority to do that so
that's what the amendment's all about it
grants rulemaking authority to the
division to be able to do that
thank you representative for taking my
question so i just have this little bit
of a conundrum in my mind that i'm
trying to settle as a parent well
they're no longer a teenager maybe 25
years ago they were a teenager but as a
parent of a teenager
what happens if the
[Music]
parent who
hopefully knows their child best
thinks that they should not
go for their driver's test yet
until they've taken a class but the
child
goes out and finds that responsible
adult for themselves
absolutely you can find that answer
another chapter of law if i'm not
mistaken it's rsa
263 colon 19.
i think that's the right no i'm sorry 17
and what that chapter says is no one
under the age of 18 get a driver's
license without their parents signature
period
so unless you're emancipating all the
other rules so so we already have that
in law as to what happens so that
doesn't need to be addressed that's
representative hill thank you mr
chairman uh thank you for taking my
question
um how would would this benefit your
your proposal would this benefit uh
those students
that
are unable to afford the commercial
driving
school
and and so they wait until they're 18
having no
driver no formal driver training and
then go uh take the test without ever
seeing any of the commercial
um
schools any of that
thank you representative hill for the
question and again you know the answer
is yes it would help them is that again
at 18 you can walk in without any
driver's education and get your driver's
license
on your birthday um you have no
obligation to learn anything
alls are doing is delaying parents and
children that could have an earlier
driver and again to the superintendent's
point that that i spoke to it is
definitely shows in single families
single parent families and and families
that are lower economic means
um have more of a struggle
on on their commitment of money and time
because a lot of times i used to like
use the argument my my brothers and
sisters in dealing with parents i can
give you money and give you time i can't
give you both right because it's too
much of a burden right to try to do both
of all those things and and that and i
think this is no different right so some
parents are willing to give the money
and send their kid off to the class and
take care of it because they can't give
the time up others have plenty of time
but don't have the money and this would
take care of both you can do it either
way you can provide the time you can
provide the money to be able to allow
your student to or a child to be able to
um get a driver's license and enter the
workforce sooner right again some of
these families that are struggling the
kid wants to get a a job down at the
mall or down at mcdonald's and this is
one of the ways the parents after coming
home from school the kid can go over and
work two hours or three hours but they
can't do that now unless the parent
wants to drive him to drive him there
driving back so
our this is definitely you know i look
at this sometimes and i i loathe to do
this sometimes but this is an economic
class issue to a certain extent that
economic classes pay a big part of this
and and the the people who are on the
most losing side are the lower economic
class
further questions
representative
but i crawford i need to ask this
question
so
another responsible adult
could be anyone 25 years or older is
that correct as long as they're licensed
yes as long as they have a new hampshire
license could that 25 year old adult
with a new hampshire driver's license
charge someone
for lessons
a parent doesn't have time to take their
kids out
are they going to be able to charge that
person is that is that 25 year old adult
going to be able to charge
that parent for the time that he's
putting in to teach their child how to
drive
so to answer your question i think and
again this is this is a little bit of a
leap for me because i didn't look up the
regulations under again
department of motor vehicle the driver's
ed instructor which is a person who
receives money for driver's education is
regulated by the department of motor
vehicle they have a couple officers back
here that enforce that
looking at their rules i would i would
make the assumption that if you were
charging and you were for driving then
you're acting as a uh license as a
driver as a driver's ed instructor
commercial driver's instructor and be
obligated to file their follow their
but in our rules and regulations um only
a licensed uh person can charge for
driving instruction that's in our
regulations and
we and driver instructors have to have
criminal checks they have to have a
driving record check every three years
they have to have
50 hours of staff development hours
which cost money to that but if i if i
as a parent don't have time and i want
my neighbor who's a good friend of mine
i don't really know his driving record
but i want to ask him hey could you take
my child out for 10 hours of driving and
i'll give you 50 bucks an hour is that
is that acceptable
so the answer your question again i
think i did once but is that um if it's
illegal now to charge and you're not a
certified instructor it would still be
legal to charge if you're not a
certified instructor that doesn't change
so you have 40 hours now
that's obligated the parents teach
anybody could do exactly what you
defined right now and it would be in
violation i'm sure of the regulations um
that that department or vehicle has
about about pain you know being
basically a commercial or professional
drivers instructor and you would have to
fall into their rules and if you didn't
i'm sure they would come after you if
there was something a complaint made but
again i don't think this law changes the
rules doesn't change the obligation that
obligation is identical as
if this bill passes versus not
seeing none thank you very much thank
you mr chairman i'll be in the room if
something comes up and you have a
question
all right
represent representative gagne uh as i
mentioned i guess we have a tag team
next um
tom prasall
and john cameron am i correct
if that's okay with the chair that's
fine with me both representing new
hampshire driver's education teachers
association
um
mr prasal said he wants three minutes mr
cameron wants five so we'll see how that
works well thank you mr chair and
members of the committee um i figured
for the sake of the committee's time we
would just do this together and uh i
would let uh john cameron who's here as
the president of the new hampshire
driver education teachers association do
the bulk of the talking and i can just
supplement where needed
thank you tom
thank you chairman walsh and members of
the committee
my name is john cameron i am the
president of the new hampshire driver's
ed teachers association
i'm here speaking on behalf of that
association in opposition to hb 1208
the state of new hampshire has placed a
priority on teen driver training and has
developed a robust driver education
training program with an emphasis on
safety as a result there are
approximately 55 to 60 certified driving
schools in the state
we provide 30 hours of classroom
instruction 10 hours of behind the wheel
instruction and 6 hours of observation
to our students
currently parents are required to
provide an additional 40 hours of
practice time
driver educators go through extensive
training for their testing and state
certifications this combined with a
specially equipped car lesson plans and
some infinite patients provides a safe
and knowledgeable environment for a
young teenager to begin the process of
becoming a competent driver in this
proposed legislation if a parent
guardian or other responsible adult
submits in writing that they have
provided for instruction the
commissioner shall grant a waiver
regardless of what that instruction
looks like
current standards for a certified driver
education instructor includes passing
eight college courses specific to
teaching driver education
passing a 100 question written exam
passing a road test completion of a
background and driving records check
completion of 300 hours of supervised
student teaching and meeting all the
standards of safe c3100
that include providing a curriculum
lesson plans and route plans
this bill in effect potentially makes
anyone with a driver's license a
certified driving instructor without
meeting any of these criteria
driving schools are the definition of a
small business and we operate on very
tight margins if this legislation were
to pass i fear it would cause a number
of driving schools perhaps a significant
number to close leaving more shortages
of professionals to provide traditional
instruction
access to classes is an issue that the
industry is actively trying to address
the department of safety along with
members of the new hampshire driver
education teachers association
aaa and other team members are currently
meeting monthly with the director's
office to address these concerns
the goal is to work towards creating
ways to increase access to classes
without compromising quality instruction
the committee has recently submitted
proposals for rural changes that would
have significant potential to make it
easier for students to take classes and
we look forward to continue this process
with the director
new hampshire certified driving
instructors are the first line of
defense in promoting safety on our
roadways driving is the single most
dangerous thing we do on a daily basis
we all have licenses each of us has a
different definition of what a good
driver is but i think we could all agree
that it's different out there now than
when we learn to drive it's more
complicated than ever we have more
vehicles than ever new technologies and
cars new roadway designs and safety
features and an increasing population of
drivers
an option already exists if students do
not want to take driver education that
state the state does not require anyone
18 or older to take any classes as a
result only 16 and 17 year olds are
required to take driver education class
from a certified instructor if they wish
to obtain a driver's license prior to
their 18th birthday there is a cost to
taking the class but that cost is
recoupable in the form of discounts
offered by insurance companies for
completing an approved driver education
course as driving instructors we are
held to standards and we have taken our
own on our own cost of becoming an
approved school
certified driving schools provide a
service to a small segment of our
population that service is as much about
the overall safety of our students and
the general population as it is about
driving a motor vehicle driving schools
employ people who have invested
significant amounts of money and time
within the state to be and remain a
certified instructor
driving schools and instructors are
overseeing and work in concert with the
department of safety
for these reasons we oppose hb 1208 and
ask the committee to find the bill and
expedite it to legislate and i'd be
happy to entertain any questions
mr chairman if i can just make a couple
of points as well i heard um you know
we've heard this bill before this
committee has numerous times
and a few of the driving factors of what
has
basically brought this bill forward have
been
access to driver's education and you
know the difficulty of
being able to drive a student to a
course
and i want to say that you know this
committee and its infinite wisdom a few
years ago
did modify the statute and that it now
allows for 15 hours of the 30 that are
in the law to be done
through a remote or online program and
those were the rules that john had just
mentioned
are being submitted through our work
with the division of motor vehicles and
department of safety
we have been meeting over the course of
the last couple of years
and of course the pandemic has slowed
some of that work down but we're back in
person
getting together on what
parts of the curriculum can be done
online which will obviously create more
access for students
to the driver education program
another issue is the cost we certainly
have heard that as john mentioned you
know these driver education schools
operate on tight margins however this
committee just heard a bill right before
this
about the driver training fund and i
think
you know representative almi had asked
that that bill be sent to interim study
for further work about providing um some
reimbursement back to the student for
the cost as was previously done before
and i think you know that's certainly a
mechanism to address the cost
and as far as
the driver education program as a whole
last year the national highway traffic
safety administration conducted a robust
look at our driver education program in
the state of new hampshire and offered
numerous recommendations and i'd be
happy to get a copy of that report
to the committee members
however i should note that
moving to a parent taught driver
education program was not one of their
recommendations
they had a number of recommendations
however this was not one of them as well
as reducing the number of hours behind
the wheel
was not one of their recommendations
which this bill does by moving it from
the
10 hours with the driver instructor six
hours observation and then 40 hours with
the parent guardian a responsible adult
this bill would just satisfy that
those hours with just 40 hours with a
responsible adult so we would
essentially be cutting back on the
driving time so again i hope that was
under two minutes but those were just
some supplemental comments i wanted to
add and we'd be happy to take any
questions
thank you any questions from the
committee
rep thompson
um i think it's john i apologize i don't
remember your last name
um
yes thanks for the question um
we have about as i said about 55 to 60
driving schools in the state there are
some areas that lack driving schools
honestly each time that
bills like this come up it kind of hurts
us in our potential to get more driving
schools up and going
but there are some schools we advise
everybody to sign up early because it is
a process and our class sizes are
limited to 30
through state rule so it's not as simple
as just wanting a course to being able
to get it it's a process of signing up
and and getting registered in the
correct class to get through but i would
think that um using my school for an
example there's nobody that waits more
than a month or two
that
doesn't get in and they're still within
their 16th birthday when they're done
which is also a requirement that
um they either have to be 15 and 9
months to begin the class which is a
something that we had proposed and got
through rule changes to try to alleviate
some of that
backlog or they have to be 16 by the
this
this is working if anyone has a question
you plugged in i guess
yeah
okay sound check all right we're back um
any further questions from the committee
representative talersky thank you thank
you for taking my question um i attended
a driver's ed school in nashua in the
late 80s my children attended the same
one
in the mid-2000s and um i've taught
with the assistants of the driver's ed
school three children how to drive in
the last couple years and one thing that
struck me is how
safety
has changed in those 25 years and the
prime example is the hand position on
the wheel
which
or the simple act of turning the wheel
and the proper way to protect yourself
which my 16 year olds told me i was
doing completely wrong and i had the uh
risk of injuring myself um with the way
i drive
would you say that
technology changing and safety
tactics or approaches to driving is
something that
does change regularly enough that if
we have adults who haven't had
up-to-date safety training on driving
that could pose a risk to
a whole generation of
drivers
thank you for the question
and you give me a chance to put my
teacher hat on which excites me so
i think we all would teach what we
learned back 20 to 25 years ago and
technology is extremely
advanced in cars nowadays so
i start off
with um the kids in the car
with did you know that you have to
connect electronically with your car to
make the the airbags and brand new cars
work properly for you and they're like
do i take my phone out no you plug your
seat belt in and then
that seat monitors where you put your
seat um how much you weigh and it'll
deploy airbags now in the on the newest
of cars at different levels for
different sized people because it wants
to help you not hurt you
hand position as you talked about we
teach nine o'clock three o'clock instead
of ten two and shuffle steering instead
of hand over hand because of airbags and
how fast airbags come out we talk about
you know 40 milliseconds and an airbag
is completely inflated in front of you
that's an explosion
so having you know the car
um you know and i tell them there's one
thing faster than in your car than
than your airbag and that's your
seatbelt actuator and pretension are
firing and tightening you to the seat
before the airbag goes off
so i would worry that parents you know
wouldn't know what is stability assist
how does it really work traction control
anti-lock brakes you know we were talk i
was taught as a kid pump your brakes
when it starts to you know lock up and
slide and that's not what new cars are
designed to do anymore so i would think
it would be
certainly a challenge for parents to
keep up with all the technology
that that new cars have to offer and and
that's something that we do in our field
is keep up with the with the new stuff
thank you for the questions
seeing none thank you very much thank
next up chair recognizes dan goodman uh
representing
aaa
thank you chair and members of the
committee for the record my name is dan
goodman
and i am the public affairs manager for
aaa northern england which is
a motor club that represents maine new
hampshire and vermont and before i get
into it i just want to
piggyback on what john was talking about
with driver ed teachers and
how what they teach kids is always
evolving
john's curriculum the schools in new
hampshire their curriculum what they're
teaching students is always changing
from distracted driving to vehicle
technology to impaired driving these
instructors go through
a vigorous
onboarding
and
and they go to numerous conferences and
they're always trying to update the
information they that they teach
students so um
it's it's quite incredible um but i
should have started by saying i'm in
opposition to this as the chairman said
um
throughout new hampshire and throughout
the country we're kind of in this this
trend where less kids are taking drive
red while vehicle crashes remain the
number one killer of teen drivers we
know teen drivers are
overrepresented in
crashes you know there's
so we know teen drivers are also three
times more likely to die in a fatal
crash than an adult driver
we also know
that um
two-thirds of people injured or killed
in a crash involving cane driver other
than that teen driver
so that's that's
um not great uh we know that you know
there are most vulnerable drivers out
there they need the best education
possible
and have being involved in instruction
with a professional instructor is vital
i only know of one study that has looked
at
a state that offers parent driver
education and then they analyze that
verse the students who took driver edge
with a professional instructor and i was
at the texas transportations too i
apologize and this research determined
that teenagers taught to drive by
someone other than the professional
driver instructor are more likely to be
convicted of driving violations
including speeding and more likely to be
involved in serious crashes
they also found that parent taught
drivers are nearly three times more
likely to be involved in a fatal crash
than our young drivers taught by
commercial or public school driver
instructors so
it's pretty scary
so we know it
has been mentioned parents play a
crucial part in dry vacation in new
hampshire as was mentioned
they have to do 40 hours before they get
their license that's a that's a key role
but the professional driver instructor
is also a very very key role that we
don't want to take out and i'm concerned
that this would pose a serious risk to
not just the teen driver but other users
every root user on the road so with that
i'm in opposition to this bill and
happy to answer any questions thank you
they let you off the hook thank you
thank you
lieutenant james o'leary representing
department of safety state police
did not say one way or the other if he
supports or opposes the bill but i
would imagine he will in a moment
i was going to keep that part of sega
good morning chairman members of the
committee morning we do oppose the bill
the
pretty much all the points have been
made so i won't
waste any of your time with with
reiterating the things that people said
before me
but as it relates to the waiver process
uh right now when somebody comes from
out of state to transfer their driver
education program to the state of new
hampshire
we are required to essentially review
the education that person received from
that state to make sure that it is
comparable to what the new hampshire
standards and curriculum speak to
in doing that it's a time consuming
process because depending on the state
we have to research essentially what
they are requirements are and what they
are teaching state law requires in new
hampshire that we speak to 45 minutes of
motorcycle safety awareness as well as
45 minutes dedicated to driving around
trucks so we have to make sure that
those programs
or that time has been met from out of
state
the reason i speak to that is
in looking at
what the waiver process would look like
for us
the language the way that it's suggested
now would have an impact on our office
as we would effectively have to review
each one of these waivers and we just
currently don't have the staff to be
able to to do that so that's how it
would affect
the state
we obviously have concerns that each one
of those waivers would represent a
different methodology or of teaching
with different driving experiences and
knowledge of law potentially poor
driving habits and all those things that
follow through that everybody spoke to
before
um so it's our belief that the
instruction provided by our driver
educators allow for a quality program uh
being delivered by trained and certified
instructors
um so that's where we stand on that if
there's any questions i'd be happy to
answer them right thank you question
did i see a hand
no
okay
i guess there are no questions thank you
very much thank you sir
uh that's the last person i have signed
up to speak on the bill is anybody else
that wishes to
seeing none i will close the public
hearing on house bill 1208 fn
and before everybody leaves
representative gagne
uh the bills that we've scheduled that
i've scheduled today uh are our early
bills the meeting that i went to earlier
was to
find out that we actually are shortening
up the schedule a little bit
um
for these early bills other than what
you see posted
so
we have an opportunity we've got 25
minutes if you can hang tight for a
minute i'm going to meet with the
ranking member
if there are any bills that we can come
to a consensus on perhaps we can exec
one or two of these
and just start getting these processed
knowing that we are going to run out of
time sooner than later so give us a few
all right
um welcome back everybody we do have a
few minutes
we are going to move into an executive
session to tackle a couple of our early
bills
so i will open up the executive session
on house bill
1489 fn
the chair recognizes representative
crawford for a motion
mr chairman i vote i mean that's okay i
make the motion itl on house bill
i make the motion to itl and house bill
okay is there a second
second
dan where did that come from
i'll let you get caught up if you would
wish to speak to your motion uh no i
don't okay
she does not is does anybody wish to
i guess that's that's pretty telling
um
with nothing uh with nothing more to add
okay i'll ask the clerk to call the roll
vice chairman gagne
yes
representative smith clerk votes yes
representative hill
representative thompson yes
representative ankerberg yes
representative gorski
yes representative o'hare is absent
representative sykes
yes
representative fenton yeah
representative rambo yes
representative rich yes
representative tulerski
yes representative fox
yes
representative stevens
she's not here representative
14 to zero okay the committee uh
recommendation of ito was adopted 14-0
move consent
motion for consent any objections to
consent
seeing none i will close the executive
session on 1489.
okay
open up the executive session on
house bill 1615 fn
john
and the chair recognizes representative
mr chairman in the interest of
collegiality i move that house bill 1615
be
interim study
interim studies the motion is there a
second second
who was that
representative gagne seconds
would you care to speak to your motion
certainly thank you so
this bill is raising up some important
issues for
questions about driver ed its
affordability
and the way that the some funds are
being distributed and there's a lot of
stakeholders involved in this and so i
believe interim study would be a good
way for us to
take a further in-depth look at the
questions and we'll have an opportunity
to talk to more of the stakeholders
and therefore would urge us to vote yes
okay thank you any further discussion
uh
i'll just mention too that it was
actually the prime sponsor that
suggested this was a good idea
so if there's no other discussion i'll
ask the clerk to call the role as soon
as she's ready okay thank you
the motion on the floor is in room study
on house bill 1615 fn
uh vice chairman gaggy
yes
clerk votes yes representative hill yes
representative thompson yes
representative ankerberg yes
representative gorski yes
representative sykes
yes
representative fenton
representative rambo yes
representative rich yes
representative talersky yes
representative fox
representative stevens
oh that's right representative value
uh chairman walsh yes
to zero
okay the committee recommendation of uh
interim study on 1615 fn
uh 14-0 uh moved on consent any
objection
seeing none consent that is i'll close
the executive session on house bill
1615.
recommendation for consent who was it um
representative okay thank you
that's those are the only two we're
going to tackle for now we've got a few
extra minutes on our lunch hour uh one
o'clock is our next public hearing house
bill 1640.
is that like warm in here is it just me
jesus
do you think we'll be doing any more
exactly
okay all right can i leave this out it
possible
like actually that's not even early
1462 in my opinion
yeah
is that
what is the difference between that and
the last one you passed
what is the difference between
[Laughter]
[Music]
i'm going to be here because i'm doing
did
larry do you have um
the blurb sheet she didn't give me any
okay welcome back everybody being 101
i'll open up the public hearing on house
bill 1640 fn relative to the payment of
motor vehicle fines
uh is representative belanger here the
seeing none as a courtesy representative
gagne can you introduce it for him
yep
mr chairman for the record
my name is representative larry gagne
and i am introducing house bill 1640 fn
relative to the payment of motor vehicle
fines
this bill allows anyone who receives a
fine related to their motor vehicle to
donate the fine amount to a charitable
organization rather than submit payment
to a state agency
i can take questions i won't be able to
thank you representative
um
start off chair recognizes marie mullen
from the department of transportation in
good morning members of the committee my
name's marie mullen i'm the director of
finance for the new hampshire department
of transportation
um and we oppose this bill
primarily because of the erosion of the
highway fund revenue we're seeing due to
fuel efficiency
we we have a study that was done by
cambridge systematics a few years ago
and the fuel efficiency the adoption of
electric vehicles hybrid vehicles
that we're has projected to see a one
percent decline in revenue per year
over the next
you know over the future 10 plus years
and so we're concerned that diverting
this revenue
to terrible organizations will continue
to hamper the highway fund and be able
to provide services
to the citizens of the state of new
hampshire thank you will you take any
questions
yup if anyone has any questions any
questions from the committee
seeing none thank you hold on
representative
thank you mr chairman and uh
thank you mr mullen for taking my
question just to kind of clarify i just
was going through this
how much of the revenue would be lost if
this was passed
um i believe the department of safety
the department of safety collects the
revenue so it's in the fiscal note
um
going out into 2024 once you see a full
year it looks like about 9.2 million to
make sure okay thank you
any further questions
next up
um
mary ann ducey
how'd i do
close from the new hampshire judicial
branch uh
not taking a position on the bill at
this point thank
thank you
ah dempsey thank you
thank you very much for the record my
name is marianne dempsey i'm general
counsel for the judicial branch
um you will see that we prepared a
fiscal note in connection with this bill
and it's because the language of the
bill is unclear as to whether the
donation of fines includes the penalty
assessment
for each motor vehicle violation by
statute there's a penalty assessment
that
ensues and that gets split amongst
a number of different
groups including the general fund but we
receive a portion through the i.t
dedicated fund for our i.t services so
if this were to pass we would estimate a
revenue loss of approximately 1.2
million
dollars
the other thing i would make note in the
bill is just that it doesn't
have a mechanism by which the court
would be notified of a payment to a
charity so
when somebody
motor vehicle violation is brought the
person either please by mail or comes
into the court so without a notice to
the court that that has been satisfied
it could also be problematic in terms of
individuals being found not to have paid
okay thank you
representative gagne
thank you mr chairman uh you talking
about the penalty assessment is that
still 20 one-fifth of the fine it i
think it depends on the nature of the
fine representative it's the statute um
is
uh 106 hyphen l colon 10 but i think it
depends it's a proportion of the fine so
i think it depends on the amount um but
for for our excuse me we we estimate
that the penalty assessment loss would
be 1.2 million per year in total thank
you thank you any further questions
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
next up
department of safety dmv
brittany and you have to help me out is
yeah welcome
in opposition to the bill
good afternoon my name is brittany shu i
am the administrator of the bureau of
financial responsibility at the division
of motor vehicles and we are testifying
opposition of this bill just like dot
and the judicial branch has pointed out
there are
fiscal impacts there are both
expenditures and revenues that would be
lost and incurred through this process
additionally the legislation is unclear
as to how this will be administered and
practiced such as how do we dictate to
the 503cs about
who can pay what can be paid what can't
be paid
does this impact an individual's driver
privacy by paying penalties through a
charity
and will the division be tasked with
going back and verifying such payments
whether they're monetary
or in exchange a different value
clothing furniture any sort of donation
to that charity
additionally it's unclear through this
legislation if it's fines pursuant to a
motor vehicle such as unregistered
uninspected
headlights tail lights any of those type
violations or whether it would also be
inclusive of mobile devices speeding
and other violations that a driver can
be charged with under title 21
and with that i'll be happy to take any
questions thank you any questions from
the committee
representative palerski
thank you miss shoot i just have a quick
question we're obviously going to lose
a lot of funds in from the dot the
judicial branch and the dmv is there any
additional
funds that would be needed if this bill
passed
i we hear all the time you need
ninety thousand dollars to change the
software to change the fine schedule
will there be additional funds needed on
top of that
so for dean thank you for your question
for dmv to adjust our database to
include our notices it would cost about
175 000 dollars to modify our database
and another ten thousand dollars in
notices and uniform fine schedule for
printing as law enforcement's required
to provide the uniform fine schedule to
anyone who is sighted along the roadside
seeing none thank you very much thank
you very much
that's the last person i have signed up
to speak is there anybody else that
i guess i misjudged how long this one is
going to take i'll close the public
hearing on house bill 1640.
next up uh will be 16 house bill 1658 at
1 30.
uh
foreign
yes
all right everybody uh as was put in our
calendar uh we
will take up some executive sessions
from time to time if time allows
this is one of them uh so i'm going to
open up the executive session on house
bill 1640 fn relative to the payment of
motor vehicle fines
chair recognizes representative gagne
for a motion
thank you mr chairman
i move itl on house bill 1640 fm
i
okay itl has been moved who was the
second
representative hill seconds
would you care to speak to motion
well mr chairman i think it's pretty
self-explanatory
all i look is the uh fiscal note here
and you know this state can't afford to
lose any of this money so
that's why i move make the motion for
itl
fair enough any further discussion
yeah i will concur uh when we have these
these bills with such large fiscal notes
it's it's nice to see an attempt to
maybe find the money in a different
place and this bill did not do that so i
also
will be supporting the itl
any
representative
thank you mr chairman yeah so i'm in
support of the itl because
it's incumbent upon us as a committee
particularly a policy committee to know
how things are actually going to work
and there's so many questions about this
bill that it's just not it's not ready
anybody else yes you do need to
with no further discussion i'll ask the
clerk to call the roll as soon as she's
ready
hi
clerk votes
representative hill
representative thompson yes
representative ankerberg yes
representative gorski yes
representative sykes
yes
representative fenton yeah
representative rambo yes
representative rich yes
representative telorsky yes
representative fox
all right and chairman walsh
yes
to zero
okay the the committee recommendation of
consent's been moved with any objections
seeing none consent that is i'll close
the
executive session on house bill 1640.
now the next bill
being 130 i'll open the public hearing
on house bill 1658 fn
relative to testing in lieu of license
renewal fees
uh
prime minister chairman yep i'm so sorry
i was out of uh the time zone
um and it put it in my phone incorrectly
i'm the prime sponsor of
1640. we've already heard the bill and
execute it all right thank you very much
i'll i'll fill you in later
okay
um
where was i i'm opening the public
hearing on house bill 1658 fn
relative to testing in lieu of license
renewal fees
um you push the button to your right it
should show up red
there you go there we go
all right as long as i'm
audible uh my name is representative max
abramson i'm representing uh hampton
hampton falls and seabrook and i'm
introducing this which i think is
probably one of the simplest bills
of the session it's
to deal with a hardship
situation
that
a lot of uh folks especially older folks
in the state encounter when they need to
uh go in and renew their their uh their
driver's license they're valid for five
years and so it's uh
it doesn't sound like much when it's ten
dollars a year but it's uh it's a 50
renewal fee and for folks both on fixed
incomes and for a lot of working poor in
our state it's actually
it can be a a sudden um
a sudden expense that they couldn't
afford so i was speaking with a
public school bus driver
who lives down the street from me and
she said
that the rules of the road have changed
a little bit over the years for drivers
and it might be useful to have people go
in and just retake the written test
every every so often and so i i thought
of
bringing these two ideas together as a
way to kind of incentivize that
um
i'm aware that there's a a fiscal note
and it's based on a rough estimate i
don't agree with either either side of
the fiscal note on this
that uh the vast majority of people who
who would be willing to
go in and restudy for the written test
another 40 or 45 minutes i think to
retake the written test it's been a long
time since i've taken the test myself as
a matter of fact i hate to admit that
the rules of the road have changed since
i moved to new hampshire over 20 years
ago
and
[Music]
we have quite a few drivers who
either don't know that they're supposed
to stop
or when the buses used to stop on route
1 which is is five lanes wide they don't
do that anymore where i live but they'll
stop and put the the stop sign out and
people on the opposite side of the road
will actually stop and stop traffic
because people don't know
um the
what the stop sign means how how uh
the fl in the fro flashing red lights
what they mean
when a school bus comes to a stop it's
only stopping the traffic right next to
the bus in that particular direction
it's only stopping traffic in two lanes
another one of course is
people not understanding how to use the
turn lane properly and there are quite a
few accidents
that happen on our roads and highways
because people don't understand
that it's the turn lane is something
that you turn into and you turn out of a
number of times i've turned into the
turn lane and come almost to a complete
stop
and someone coming the other way
where i wasn't even turning into their
lane
will
honk and screech and one
woman almost went off the road because
she didn't understand how the turn lanes
worked
so
the driver's licensing fee we have a
tendency to talk about it in terms of
revenue but the argument for drivers
licensing is that it's supposed to make
the roads and highways safer
the the reality of of course is
that uh there have been a number of
studies that come out showing that
people who get a driver's license are
actually more likely to cause an
accident and people have never bothered
to get a driver's license at all
so
[Music]
in my opinion we have to revise the
whole process
so that people at a minimum know the
rules of the road and that we
do suspend people's licenses
um
at least for driving at night if they're
if they're driving recklessly
or if they're
if they're causing multiple accidents
that that on on one hand we've been
making the case to the public that
driver's licenses are supposed to
improve road safety and and keep the
occasional really bad driver off the
road or at least reform them so that
they drive a little bit more safely
on the other hand i believe that we're
duty bound to offer some type of
hardship provision and i don't
i don't like the idea of having people
go to their bank
and get
you know
bring back statements from their bank
bring back pay stubs and everything else
that we do with
you know community action in the town
welfare office and so forth to prove a
hardship i think that it would be
sufficient just to have them reset for
the test
um and demonstrate a hardship that way
the way that most other states have
addressed this is simply by keeping the
driver's license renewal fee low
quite a few states simply have renewal
rather than having the higher fifty
dollar fee
and uh
that
that would also work in my opinion but i
think that that for for people who are
kind of struggling to make ends meet
that there has to be a hardship
provision that's offered at the time
that licenses are are renewed and i
think it's
it's a mistake to
continue to let drivers
for financial reason either drive
without a drive with an expired driver's
license or not be able to drive at all
the state loses a lot of jobs and a lot
of revenue and a lot of jobs go unfilled
because
people hit that point where they need to
renew their driver's license they just
financially are not able to afford it
so for those reasons i think that the
bill is a good idea
i the second part of the fiscal note
that i disagreed with was the additional
testing facilities i think that it's
that there's already a mechanism in
place for brand new drivers
to uh to sit for the written test and i
i
i think although very few people would
actually take advantage of this
uh the few people who do it i think
would just be using the existing
facilities
taking the in the
driver's manual studying it and and
sitting for the test the same way a new
driver would
thank you
thank you any questions from the
committee
representative thompson
so was your intention here to
to not create a hardship for those
people or to
educate them i i
not sure we can have it both ways i
my concern is and i took my driving test
before you were born
and there were 10 questions that were
very easy in a five minute driving test
i'm wondering if where
you're putting people at risk of not
being able to get a license renewal
because they can't answer questions
they've not had to answer for 40 years
well
people like that if they don't know what
the rules of the road are i'm leery
about them
driving at all maybe instead of maybe
instead of a fifty dollar fee no one
should be able to just pay the fifty
dollar renewal fee everyone should have
to retake the test when i took the test
in washington
oh this was a long time ago
uh
i think it was
it took me almost an hour to get through
the test i did score 96
but there were quite a few people who
just
you know they would have to retake the
test like three times and they would
i mean so mine my intent is to get
people to study my intent is first offer
sorry first to offer a hardship
provision if people are facing a
hardship that they can still get their
driver's license renewed and then
secondly i'd also like to get people to
actually study the the purpose of
driver's licensing is is literally to
make the roads safer and this is a it's
a small way to do it
um that would get at least a few people
uh actually cracking open the book and
learning what the new rules of the road
are
okay thank you sir great further
questions representative hill
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
i'm gathering this as a voluntary
option so
so a person could decide to pay the fee
or they could decide to take the written
test and not pay a fee
um
and i guess my questions are if someone
takes the option to take the written
test and they fail
do they then have the option to just pay
the fee and and get their license back
or are they on this path now that they
have to pass that test before they get
their license no there's there's nothing
in the in the bill that would um
that would address that so if you
if somebody did take the test and they
completely failed it they would still be
able to pay the fifty dollar fee just as
they're able to right now
so
uh you know my my preference is if we're
going to have driver's licenses and
we're going to assure the drivers that
people are safe to drive on the road i
would have everybody retake the written
test every at least every you know 10 or
15 years but we don't require that right
now we just say pay the 50 fee and
you're back on the road
and
now
if this committee would like to change
that and say well if you fail the test
you have to re-do it until you pass the
test that that that would be one thing
but that's not what the effect of the
bill is the bill just offers uh
uh you know a study and retake
alternative
follow-up please follow up thank you
so
the bill is silent on that but what what
would you ideally like to have happen if
someone
um
if if someone fails that exam you you
would like them to continue to have to
keep taking it but you don't say that in
this bill well i don't know what would
happen i don't think that would have a
chance of
passing in reality but i i
personally if you're asking my opinion i
think that every 10 or 15 years everyone
should have to retake the written test i
guess when i'm i follow
i guess what i'm asking is
what happens if this were to pass and
someone fails that test then they can
just pay the 50 fee right like they do
right now
okay thank you so it wouldn't help in
that circumstance but at least they
would read the at least they'd be
reading the instruction manual they'd be
learning a little more material at least
for the questions from the committee
representative tillerson
thank you
representative abramson i love the
idea of trying to help those who are
not able to pay to get their license
however i'm concerned
that i don't see anything that
prevents
just someone
going to do it to save the fifty dollars
i can see that the fiscal note as we all
have seen is quite quite extensive so
is there any concept of how to control
um
the number of people who could take
advantage of it yeah basically somebody
who makes 300 or 400 or 500 a day is not
likely to take a half a day off of work
to come in
you know get the driver's manual spend
an hour studying and and then take
another 45 minutes or an hour to retake
the test you'd lose you'd lose half a
day
so it doesn't make sense for them to
lose
you know potentially two or three
hundred dollars in income just to avoid
a fifty dollar fee
it it's
mostly disabled
people on fixed income low income
elderly uh working poor people who are
making you know 10 12 15 an hour who
would be
be considering this because you have to
if if
i have to take a half a day of work off
most people if they have to take a half
a day of work off just to go re take
this test it's a hundred or two hundred
dollars in lost income so it isn't it
isn't economically worth it for them it
is for the unemployed it is for the
disabled
i i've got to ask a couple myself then
um
i mean i appreciate what you're doing
it's actually a pretty creative way of
taking care of a couple of issues that
you've identified however i think it's
kind of problematic based on some of the
questions to try to relate them
together
that's just a statement in terms of a
question you said you disagreed with the
fiscal notes
because you don't expect many people
would do it but would you agree that as
a committee when we make these decisions
that we should look at the worst case
scenario
which is what i read this fiscal note as
being because it said could when up to
so that's the worst case scenario of
people you know maximizing and using
this do you agree that it's probably
accurate if everybody did it
i did
uh now
i just got the the bill i was told that
there is estimating that something like
15 percent of drivers wouldn't
15 percent of drivers would prefer to
i'm not quite sure what the methodology
i don't think it's realistic that a
large number of people would use it but
i would prefer that a large number of
people use it even if we did lose even
if the state did lose some revenue
if most people or a large number of
people would actually go re-study the
rules of the road and then also retake
the test and pass the test
uh most people would pass the written
test if they studied for it
um
but i don't
i don't i don't
expect that there would be a large
loss in revenue i don't i don't think in
other words i don't think that this
would be a huge success i don't think
that you'd have
thousands and thousands of people
coming in and taking advantage of this i
think that maybe a few hundred people
based on that i'll leave it alone
any other questions from the committee
seeing none thank you very much
uh the only pink card i have uh brittany
um i'm here on behalf of the department
as we're opposed to this bill as well
um as you can see there is pretty
significant revenue impact along with
significant
expenditures to the department
between programming our database system
dmv recently modernized our database
back in 2017 so a lot of what we do
has been programmed automatically
depending on the transaction types for
individuals that come in to process a
transaction between capturing their data
capturing their information so that way
the customer has a better experience at
dmv we would need to reprogram our
system to meet
the details of this legislation
additionally with the staffing
to kind of address the question about
testing stations it's not so much
establishing a physical location it's
more or less having the right equipment
at each of the locations
should there be a demand to increase
testing we have automated testing
systems again
these systems are contracted through a
vendor they're offered testing in seven
different languages so if we need to
have more testing stations available
to meet the needs for those who opt to
do the testing rather than pay their
license renewal fees we need to have
more of those stations available
more stations equal more testers equal
more staffing that we would need to have
to support those because each time a
person
has a question they can hit the help
button and one of our staff members go
back and try to help with that situation
so everyone has a good fair opportunity
while taking their test
additionally if we have more testing we
have our fixed locations a lot of them
in which we have been at for quite a
long time we'd have to change the fit up
to accommodate more of those testing
stations
whether expanding the testing rooms the
size
shifting around the offices so we if we
go from four stations to five stations
six stations ten stations whatever that
number might be
in addition to the fiscal impacts we
have concerns on the administration of
the legislation representative hill
brought up a very good point what
happens if a person does fail the test
will they be allowed to pay that fifty
dollar fee again you'd have to stop that
transaction go to a different
transaction type
and how many times can a person fail
before
they are not eligible again if we're
talking about safety of the roadways if
they're repetitiously failing those
tests are they fit to be a driver but we
say they can turn around and end up
so as a department what is our
responsibility when that comes down if
this legislation does pass
it says that the director shall drop
rules
so then we would have to change the
administrative rule set on driver
licensing
we'd have to take into consideration
path a b and c or additionally redefine
that rule set which again
if you're familiar with the
administrative rule process it can take
a while to get through that to ensure
that it does meet the business needs and
the practice and the intent of the
legislation
generally it's unclear
it's
fiscally impactful to
the department and the state with that
i'll be happy to take your questions
although i am not well worth well versed
in the driver licensing realm i'll take
your questions if there's nothing i can
answer then i'll be happy to get those
answers for you
thank you questions from the committee
representative hill
uh thank you for taking uh my question
i um
i'm wondering
whether the department has any thoughts
or
other states have any thoughts about the
the point that representative abrasion
made about
information going stale
the the information that i had when i
got my driver's license
probably is not
fresh any longer
so
aside from a program like this what what
other type of
idea does the department have for
updating the the knowledge base that we
have as drivers
thank you very much for your question
that is an excellent question
i know that we work closely with the
american association of motor vehicle
administrators amba and we always try to
find the best practices and the best
ways to keep our roadways safe i think
that's an excellent question that i'll
take forth to my management to ensure
where we stand with those
follow-up thank you
the other
question i had when you when you were
speaking about uh physical locations in
order to to make this happen i know
um with boating licenses where uh people
are able to take uh the boating exam
online um so i'm wondering if something
like that um
system that currently is in place
um
couldn't be adopted for
allowing
this kind of an approach so that someone
could take that same exam online and
have that applied towards their license
thank you for that i think we would have
to look um very closely at that because
there is opportunity where there's
online there is opportunity if it's not
being monitored by officials there is
that potential that a different person
could take that test there's a
possibility that they have the manual
open while they're taking that test and
if we're trying to test people to ensure
that our roadways are safe
we would have to explore the risk versus
i have one if you don't mind i'm going
to go where i was going to with the
previous speaker
because for me obviously it's the fiscal
note that i'm looking at
you you did well explaining all the
expenditures in terms of the testing
stations etc can you go a little deeper
into your methodology with the revenue
and the decrease in revenue of what's it
saying
13 million to possibly 15
million 600
000 can you just explain where that was
driven from or drive from thank you for
that question
i do not think i would be able to
intelligently speak to that in totality
um again i'm filling in for the person
that was here
was supposed to be here today but if we
took every single person in the state of
new hampshire who opted to do
the testing in lieu of paying the
renewal fees depending on their
licensure type whether it's a driver's
license or whether it's a real id
that is where that impact is going to
come from so if we have 260 000 licenses
a year and at 50 to 85 depending on the
licensure type that is your potential
impact okay so it's the number if
everybody did it
based upon 260 000 licenses
further questions
cnn thank you very much thank you i have
no other people signed up to speak on
this bill one last call is there anybody
else that wishes to
seeing none i'll close the public
hearing on house bill
uh
our next public hearing
is scheduled for
two o'clock
and that's on house bill 1462.
okay being
i'll call the public hearing on house
bill
1462 fn relative to motorcycle learners
permits
and the prime sponsor
representative yakovovic
thank you mr chair members of the
committee for hearing my bill this got
to do with the permitting process for
the motorcycle
the motorcycles permit
uh this was something that bro was
brought to my attention from one of the
online forums where a lady who was
trying to get
on the motorcycle license um
went through the course registered for
the course which was
a little ways off because there is a
line for the course she went through the
course she went through the training she
went to take the test
and she made a mistake and she failed
the test
so she wanted to practice some more but
her trouble was that the permit chapter
ain't expired because it was right
um
during the summer rainy season the
unusual rainy season that we had all of
july and part of june that you couldn't
ride
and practice
so the permit that she obtained
initially was kind of useless to her
because she worked and and the few
weekends she had it rained hard and i it
probably is not a good idea for
a newbie to be out in the rain trying to
learn the skill
so so what i'm trying to solve here with
the bill is a simple
scheduling issue where people can come
back and request a renewal to the permit
so they can have more time to practice
when she posted it online a bunch of
other people chimed in saying yeah they
ran into the same issue it was
troublesome it was probably not the
doing business so i think for our
citizens sake and for safety's sake i
want people to practice as much as
possible before they actually get on the
i i would like this bill passed
so the the options after she
explained to the people online and i i
had communications with her afterwards
uh the options that some people were
giving her was one option was find a
trailer find some private property tow
your bike to the property and practice
there
because you cannot get a permit for the
roads even back roads anywhere somebody
else said enroll in another class which
is the intermediate level or the next
advanced level and she said that she
tried but again it was a scheduling
issue so they were pushed out a couple
weeks or maybe a month or two
from where from the summer
um
so that put her into fall maybe winter
and then somebody and a bunch of other
people said just
hop on and ride nobody's going to bother
yeah
yeah so so that's not something i would
advise people do
currently
um that's why i'm putting forward this
build i think it's a
sensible way to solve the issue to give
our people more chances to practice to
be safe
to work around their busy schedule you
know everybody's busy in life and
the weather um impact
which we do not control
so
um
i think that's all i got thank you for
listening all right thank you any
questions from the committee
representative tolerski
perhaps it's a question for the chair
would you be so kind as to explain what
the current situation is when you get
through the motorcycle testing program
um the time frame you have to get your
test done or how good is it long for or
you know what i mean how long is it good
for well right now the permit the
learner's permit is only good for 45
days and you and it was put in the
statute that way that you only get a
single one
to prevent people from getting a permit
and then a permit in the permit and
actually never getting taking the test
and getting an actual license
so
that's what happened to this person i'm
assuming is that it expired because of
the month of july it basically rained
every day
um
so what this bill just seeks to do is
just give you a one-time
extension to apply one more time so so
then you now you're looking at a total
of 90 days
that i hope i answered your question
i think so i just wanted to understand
what the process was no it's just it's a
single
extension one more period of time of 45
days
just in case anybody in that situation
runs into a situation that they can't
complete it in the first 45 days
and can i ask you one more question
so if you they take the motorcycle
course they get their permit they go for
their license and they fail do they have
to wait a certain time period before
trying again that i can't answer you
okay that i'm not sure thanks maybe he
can okay not quite but it's a matter of
scheduling to take the test but while
you're waiting for the test to be
retaken you may want to practice but if
the permit is exp has expired it's a one
life
it's a lifetime permit for 45 days it's
one once in a lifetime you can get it
okay so what i'm trying to do here is
extend it i saw a hand go up you might
well if you if you can help us um if you
want to just fill out a grab a pink card
you can give it to me later come on up
and introduce yourself
i'm uh i'm larry crow i'm with the
division of motor vehicles i also run
the motorcycle rider training program
um and and to clarify over here there's
there's two ways to get your motorcycle
license in the state one is to go
through the program be successful no
permit required the other way which this
is addressing is to get a permit
and then have 45 days to practice and
you need to schedule that skill test
within those 45 days
so once you the 45 day ticking clock
includes both um
uh practicing time on your own as well
as the time you need to be able to be
able to legally get to a dmv to take the
test
does that make sense
or did i did i declarify
no can i just clarify one thing
absolutely so you can actually get a
motorcycle license in the state without
going through the state program
yes if you teach yourself or if you are
18 or older the motorcycle training
program is optional
okay and so this whole permit thing
doesn't even come into play if you do
the motorcycle training program that is
correct thank you
any further questions from the committee
representative hill
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
um
i have a question on the fiscal note um
so it would seem to me if someone goes
additional 45 days to to take the exam
they would pay a renewal of that permit
twenty five dollars
and yet it shows
no income
no revenue from this only a twenty eight
thousand dollar expenditure
and so i'm trying to figure out where
does the
for those people that would take this
where does that 25
show up in the fiscal note
as additional revenue
well it says it's indeterminate so the
revenue to the state isn't determined
it's thirty dollars it's 25 plus five
more
um
there's a hit for reprogramming the
machines to be able to track it
but
yes for every renewal thirty dollars
should be collected
thank you
thank you um
so it would seem to me that um
having to reprogram
to allow the one-time renewal of the
learner's permit um they've got an
there's a number assigned to that of 28
but
um but there would be some offset to
that
from depending on how many people
utilize the the one-time renewal
at twenty-five dollars a pop
does that seem fair to say uh yes thank
you yeah yes that's exactly right they
just cannot say i guess
how many people will be renewing right
but they know how much it would cost to
correct to program i thank you
further questions from the committee
[Music]
yes
is there a fee for the motorcycle
training program
in which you don't need to apply for the
permit
uh correct yes it's
currently 155 dollars
but you must pass the test par which is
part of the program at the end of the
program and if you fail like this lady
did
she needs to get the permit and she got
the permit which expired
um
i'm sorry no problem thank you
so she was involved in the motorcycle
training program
that is correct she went through that
she failed and by the time she was ready
to retake the test she couldn't practice
because her permit on top of it expired
and the permit
she
automatically received with the training
program
i i believe she purchased it separately
okay just to be
yeah
like she was trying to cover all bases
it's going to take a while to get used
to these things any other questions from
the committee
representative thompson
director do you have any idea how often
it is a um we get phone calls from folks
at motorcycle rider training whenever
anything on two wheels comes up and we
regularly do get questions from folks
that either have
recently received a permit
and
are interested in renewing and then
learn that they can't although at this
point most people do understand that we
also get requests from people that have
gotten a permit in the past in a
returning maybe they want to get
they let their motorcycle license lapse
and want to bring it back
and it doesn't matter how long ago they
took the per they did receive a permit
it's a it's a one in a lifetime so they
are also blocked from getting a permit
they got one in 2005. um they cannot get
one in 2022. they can just go take the
test again i'm sorry
follow up follow up
they can all you can always take the
test
you just can't get a permit
you could the way that the law is
written it's it's one you can only get
one in your lifetime so if they got one
back in 2005 maybe they got their
license maybe they didn't but for some
reason in you know i'm just making a
date up here 2005 they got it um it's in
our system and now they are not eligible
to get another one
at this point
thank you representative
thank you thank you for taking my
question
what advice do you offer these people
that call and and
are looking for
for input on what they can do especially
that person that
maybe let their license lapse and want
to start again
so there are a couple options they're
not completely blocked from ever getting
a motorcycle license again
and i um and as the woman indicated
some options are
you do not have to have a permit in
order to take the test at the dmv
keeping in mind there's two ways to do
it motorcycle training take the test
you just have to be able to get your
motorcycle to the dmv legally and
especially if you're not successful get
it out of there legally we can't
fail you in the test and see you right
away
that's a that's a very bad day
for you as we like to say
um
so they may trailer it there another
very common thing is to have a friend
with a motorcycle license bring the
motorcycle down and of course the way
that i like
you can always take the motorcycle rider
training program no permit required and
if you're if you are fully successful at
that you get your motorcycle license
that way
representative crawford
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question so you can take the
you can oh sorry
uh so you can take the uh
uh motorcycle trading as many times as
you want but you can't but you only can
take the you can only get a one permit
that is correct the only thing that has
a uh
a limit is the permit
uh you can take the motorcycle training
as often as you want and you can also
take the test directly from the dmv
twice
if you have uh if you're unsuccessful
two times in a row
you are required to take the training
program that's also in the law thank you
thank you so we all know that practice
makes perfect and practice is what's
going to make us safe riders and drivers
so if
someone can't practice
how are they going to
improve
to be able to
take their license exam
other than
take the rota motorcycle training course
there's no other option to legally
practice
without the permit i think that's what
i'm getting
i believe you're correct thank you thank
you
any further questions okay
representative thompson
oh i'm sorry i didn't say
you've already been around once
thank you for taking my question what
was the original rationale for the one
i i do not have an answer i'm sorry i
before my time as i mentioned to prevent
people from just getting permit after
permit at the permit and never actually
getting a license
representative thompson
director how long does it take to take
the safety course
and
what
do you allow them a permit
while they're taking it if it's a
it is a multi-day course it is done on a
closed course under our supervision on
our motorcycles so a permit is not
um
but i guess my question is are they
given a permit while they're taking that
course
in order to go and
no right no because we're going to
during the course they will receive that
test
we provide all the practice for them
during the course
i don't often ask general questions like
this but
is there any downside to issuing a
one-time extension to the motorcycle
either one is there a downside to this i
haven't seen one i just figured i'd ask
i do not see one either thank you okay
thank you
i concur thank you very much for any
further questions from the committee
okay seeing that i'm going to close the
[Music]
do you think it's highly controversial
oh i'm not ready to execute this one oh
you don't okay that's why we just
yeah
that's fine that's fine i haven't really
had a chance to i wasn't here
okay we'll have a chat we've got it's
quarter past we still have time if you
decide
our next public hearing will be at 2
all right everybody um
being
2 30 i'll open up the public hearing on
house bill 1464
establishing a committee to study the
feasibility and implementation of
furthering electric vehicle adoption in
new hampshire
chair recognizes the prime sponsor
representative fenton
uh thank you mr chairman ladies and
gentlemen the committee i am
representative donovan fenton for the
record and i represent keane
i'm here to talk to you about
establishing a committee to study the
feasibility and implementation of
furthering electrical vehicle adoption
in new hampshire and that's a mouthful
so i apologize for the verbiage on that
so as you know most car manufacturers
are pledging to have most of their fleet
be electric or decided to be fully
electric
most have declared this to happen by
2030 which is not far away
general motors has said that they will
be fully electric by the year 2035. uh
this includes their new hummer
chevrolet has also said that their new
silverado ev will be out in the next
year
ford plans to increase its production
capacity of electric vehicles to up to
600 000 units by 2023.
this includes their new lightning f-150
ev
so the reasoning behind this bill is
that new car dealers in new hampshire
won't be getting as many of these evs as
compared to the other states around us
manufacturers send these cars to other
states because they get incentives to do
so this can lead our this can lead ours
this can let our constituents leave new
hampshire to purchase these cars
elsewhere
my hope for this bill is to study and
find creative ways where we can sell
these cars in new hampshire this bill
will hopefully help support and develop
a way to sell zero mission vehicles here
in new hampshire without adhering to any
mandates if you have any questions feel
please feel free to ask them dan bennett
was supposed to back me up but he's
caught up in the senate so it's just me
be nice thank you thank you
any questions from the committee right
here representative gagne thank you mr
chairman
representative fenton
i am on the new hampshire transportation
council right now
and
we have been tasked to study all these
things as far as like
ev vehicles by 2030
charging stations
well let me run down the list here
the duties of the council shall be to
study methods of implementing new
transportation technologies and modes of
transportation throughout the state of
new hampshire including but not limited
to those related to the bus rail highway
marine and air transportation and we're
doing all that and the logistics of such
technologies and modes investigate
methods of encouraging investment in new
techno
technologies for transportation make
recommendations to the appropriate state
agency or committee of the general court
solicit input from representatives of
disability communities elder trucking
industry attorneys with expertise in
transportation liability the insurance
industry
we just had a meeting this past friday
and
what you'd like to establish here in my
opinion is the same thing as what we're
doing already
my opinion i think is i think we have a
sufficient amount of
of committees already
and i think senator waters should
who is
who has testified in front of our
committee the the council i should say
uh
i was really hoping there was a question
there somewhere right now be aware
are you aware of this oh i wish you had
grabbed me before this and i would have
run out of the room but um no i wasn't
aware so
like i said earlier this and thank you
for the question uh but um no so the
more um this feels more geared towards
how do we
get around these mandates with getting
these cars into new hampshire so when a
when a constituent or a new hampshire
resident goes to purchase one of these
vehicles in new hampshire they
are a disadvantage because that new
hampshire car dealer might only get one
of that ev whereas the massachusetts
dealer gets 15 to 20 of those evs
because of certain mandates so that's
what the intent of this bill was you
know if you think it overlaps with that
you know i wish i had known about that
earlier um and senator waters um but
yeah that's the intent of this bill
okay further questions from the
committee
well seeing none i have just one yeah
just i've asked the question before the
last time we talked about electric
vehicles
tesla spent a lot of their own money
creating the infrastructure even in the
state of new hampshire
has four gm or any of the other
manufacturers
offered to participate in the
infrastructure for these electric
vehicles or they are waiting for this to
become part of
the public responsibility so they can
benefit
uh thank you for the question mr chair
uh that'd be a question better for dan
um but i would hope so um i know the
infrastructure is severely lacking for
these vehicles um
you know in keene especially there's no
charging stations for these cars
any other questions
representative telersky
thank you i'm not sure if i i was busy
digging for my copy of the bill i
couldn't find it because i may have
missed the beginning of what you were
saying
but
do i understand that what you're saying
is
new hampshire
is lacking
certain incentives for the cars to get
here in the first place so even if there
are buyers
willing to buy and dealers willing to
sell
there's certain things that are making
manufacturers send cars to other states
is that what we're trying to figure out
yeah thank you for the question that
that that is accurate um the states
around us
adhere to certain mandates where they
get the manufacturers get incentives to
push their cars to those states i'm not
saying new hampshire doesn't get any of
these cars but they get a
significant less amount uh than the
other states around us so a lot of
customers are leaving new hampshire to
go to these other states to purchase
these vehicles
seeing none thank you very much thank
you guys and i have no other people
signed up to speak on this
is there anybody here wishing to speak
on house bill 1464.
cnn i'll close the public hearing
um
we may we're going to have a discussion
now but the possibility of going back
into executive session
um
if we don't uh our next public hearing
and final one for the day will be at
three o'clock house bill one one one
zero
okay folks welcome back uh as i said
earlier her calendar
does read that we we may take up some of
these in executive session as time
permits
and time is permitting so we're going to
take up a couple of more this afternoon
i'm going to open the executive session
on house bill 1658 fn relative to the
testing in lieu of license renewal fees
the chair recognizes representative hill
thank you mr chairman
i would like to move interim study on
1658 fn second seconded by
representative gagley
you wish to speak to motion
briefly um
i think there's enough here that uh that
could
truly be an interim study um i think
the idea i think we all said that uh the
idea
is laudable to uh increase our product
knowledge here of of the road and the
rules
and i think there may be some
uh questions that need to be buttoned
down for instance um what happens if
someone
uh fails that the test and then is able
to pay the fee and and get the license
is that correct or not so i think it's
worth
brain cells wasted
by looking at
interim study and see if we can uh see
if we can
add some more details to this maybe for
a bill next year
i'm getting a little bit confused 1658
was the bill that you called
oh
and i what i was hearing his testimony
relative to
some other bill i thought
no i don't believe that the testing no
that's the one 1658
okay
all right representative
abramson and ankerberg um
that's the one we heard at 1 30 this
afternoon
seeing none
um
oh representative
um i just wanted to point out that the
fiscal note on this is a definite worst
case scenario so if this motion passes i
would encourage those working on it to
make sure that our department does not
um see a worst case scenario
thank you
fair enough
anybody else
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to call
the role as soon as she's ready the
motion on the floor is interim study on
house bill 1658
uh vice chairman gaggy
yes
clerk votes yes
representative hill yeah
representative thompson yes
representative ankerberg yes
representative gorski yes
representative sykes
yes
representative fenton yes representative
rambo yes representative rich
representative toloroski yes
thank you
and representative walsh i mean chairman
13 13 nothing
13 13.
all right so the committee
recommendation of interim study on house
bill 1658 is adopted 13-0
is there a motion for consent yeah
consent's been moved any objections
consent that is i'll close the executive
session on house bill 16 58.
give us a few minutes to reset we are
going to take on one more before we get
well i've been notified today that we're
no longer doing paper reports
so for the first time in my 10 years
here
i can't say that they have to be in my
hand before you leave the room
so i would like them as soon as you can
electronically
sent to me
we will make sure you get out the
correct
template if you need one
um and i'll say it publicly i'm glad
we're being watched now with days by
everybody monitored if they will
and if i don't get them
then committee services can track you
[Laughter]
okay
i'm going to open up the executive
session on
house bill 1462 fn relative to
motorcycle learners permits chair
recognizes representative thompson for a
motion
okay motions out to pass is there a
second
second second by representing
care to speak to emotion
um
this seems like a very reasonable
request
given that the department doesn't seem
to object although they didn't consent
and
where they allowed two uh two chances at
any further discussion and i just
noticed your microphone wasn't on we've
all got to get used to these things uh
62. sorry
boy this one's given me trouble
notice i transposed it on the original
schedule too
seeing none uh i'll ask the clerk to
call the role as soon as she's ready the
motion on the floor
is
ought to pass on 1462.
vice chairman gagne yes
uh clerk votes yes representative hill
representative thompson yes
representative ankerberg yes
representative gorski yes
representative sykes
yes
representative fenton yes
representative rambo yes
representative rich yes representative
talarsky yes representative fox
13.
okay the committee recommendation of
ought to pass on 1462 13-0
motion for consent
so move representative gagme
without any objection consent that goes
i'll close the executive session on
house bill 14
62.
and looking at the time
we've got one bill left at three o'clock
um
we'll stop now and see you in 10 minutes
oh
[Laughter]
okay i call
i'm leaning back to session called house
bill one one
one one one zero relative to windshield
representative walsh iran
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee uh for the record my name is
tom walsh i'm a representative from the
town of hooksett
uh and today i offer you house bill
1110.
um relative to windshield tint waivers
now
you all know and remember i'm sure that
last year we were we finally changed the
law to allow for after-market tinting
on the side windows of the operator
this issue came up
actually at the time director bolecki
this just deals with the medical waivers
that we never touched this is currently
in statute
we changed the light transmittance
allowance to the aftermarket tinting to
70 percent based on the way it's
measured nowadays
and then we looked at the waiver and it
currently allows for 35 light
transmittance with the waiver on the
windshield
and that's just about limo black on the
windshield all this build does is match
it with what we passed last year at 70
percent
still would require the waiver from the
department for the windshield but at
least it's at a the same level is that
we already have allowed on the sides and
not overly dark
so that's all it does it's a
housekeeping bill it was just something
that was discovered
after the fact
nope
sorry just for the record did this come
from
the department yeah thank you yeah she
approached me
i was just at the committee of
conference last year because they were
going through rules or getting ready to
go through rules and that's when she
discovered the issue by that time it was
too late for us to do anything so i said
we'll tackle it in the fall or next year
which is where we are
any other questions
seeing none you're letting me off the
did you did you want to
chairman walsh you promised no more
window tint bills for the
[Laughter]
people wishing to speak then i close
okay i open
the executive session on house bill one
one one
zero
thank you mr chair i'd like to move out
to pass on house bill one one one zero
second
get seconded by uh representative
thompson
all right any discussion sure thank you
thank you mr chair as i said a few
minutes ago this is a housekeeping bill
this was something that was missed last
year when we made the changes to the
tinting levels of 70 on the windows left
and right of the operator
this part of the bill was not touched
and it was recognized after the fact
that it still allowed for a 35 percent
light transmittance on the windshield
which everybody um
found concerning this changes it to 70
to match what we currently allow by
statute on the left and right side
windows by waiver only
again housekeeping
thank you
yes go ahead represent hill um question
i should have asked the sponsor earlier
but um
does this have anything to do with or
does it affect
the um
the line of tinting that's on the
windshield that um
you know right along the surface that
has been there for
years
uh on some cars
no thank you for the question and
actually i think a lot of people that
looked at this when we were making the
changes last year assumed that when it
was talking of windshield that's all it
was referring to
but after having a discussion with the
director of motor vehicles that was an
assumption that was wrong
this currently
as it's written
currently would allow 35 light
transmittance on the entire windshield
and so that's why we want to change it
to at least 70. thank you for that
clarification but what um
did the director mention at all what
happens to that
that i don't even know what to call it
that shade strip that that does come
on some vehicles that's right at the
um the roof line
that's been there for years on a number
of cars
years and years and years
i don't i don't want to set up a stage
where that is
going to be i don't know illegal or
well if i can message you absolutely
i don't believe those are currently
illegal but i guess if you do apply it
to the whole windshield it would be
slightly darker at the top
i still don't see it illegal and i don't
see it in the statute
i don't even know if those
strips are still even being done on
manufacturers that was something i used
to see in the 70s and 80s but
i get well i don't own anything that new
so i'm not sure if they still do it but
but i haven't seen anything in the
statute that would make an issue there
okay
representative sykes i might offer some
clarification too this is after-market
tint correct as well it has nothing to
do with something that came with the car
in its original manufacture correct
correct
any other questions or comments
seeing none clerk you may call the roll
all right i don't know how i'm gonna do
this i'm gonna be the vice chair i'm the
vice chair okay
oh
yeah
okay
vice chair walsh yes
uh clerk votes yes representative hill
yes
representative thompson yes
representative angerberg yes
representative gorski yes representative
sykes
yes representative fenton
oh he left okay
uh representative rambo yeah
representative rich yes representative
tillerson yes representative
oh vayu you're here yes okay
one more representative fox yes i'm
sorry
i'm skipping over stevens
votes 13
to
0. and
executive session on house bill one one
one zero
thank you representative uh europe
welcome mr chairman
the body does not want to move that's
okay
we did um all the early well this is
still on yes well thanks everybody for
today we took care of
looks like four of our early bills we
have three left to exact we'll take
those up next tuesday
just for everybody's planning purposes
tuesday is our day
it's historically been the committee day
for transportation anyway
um fridays were getting old last year so
i'm glad glad that we were able to get
tuesdays back
so
i will uh be getting the schedule out
for next week
and
stay tuned we'll see you all then thank
you very much
next week
next tuesday at nine
yeah well just
as a method of operation we've got 39
bills officially there is another one
coming
what i'm being told from the senate
fast-tracked
puts us up to 40 and the deadlines are
tight this year so
i'm going to do some busy days some long
days but fewer of them
so we can make sure everything's done
and save some mileage so
nine o'clock
uh next tuesday uh bills to be announced
you